Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Was ist die China-Chinesen da wieder für Zeug draufschreiben, Mann?
Echt Leder, ist klar.
Ja, sowas hier brauche ich, genau.
Doch, da passen, da passen die, das ist ja ein DT-770 im Prinzip.
Doch, doch, das passt auch.
Aber ich brauche auf jeden Fall mal neue.
Sind schon wirklich bisschen, ja, bisschen fest und bewegen sich nicht mehr richtig.
Die sind ja auch schon ein paar Jahre alt.
Wird mal Zeit.
Da wieder was Neues dran zu pappen.
An mein Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer habe ich letztens erst welche dran gemacht.
Auch so ein 15-Euro-Ding von Amazon, funktioniert wunderbar.
Wobei die ein bisschen zu schnell kaputt gegangen sind.
Ich habe mir ja mal vor ein paar Jahren so den QuietComfort 35 Kopfhörer gekauft.
Wegen Bahnfahren und im Büro arbeiten und Noise-Canceling.
Und da sind jetzt nach ein paar Jahren schon die Polster aufgeplatzt.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, ganz schön billig.
Stimmt, das ist eine gute Idee.
Du hast recht, das ist eine gute Idee.
Eigentlich könnte man die einfach mal waschen, die Polster.
Ja.
Du hast recht, eigentlich könnte man die einfach mal waschen.
Weil letztendlich, wenn ich mir das hier so angucke, letztendlich ist das hier einfach nur Stoff.
Das ist eine gute Idee, das probiere ich mal.
Einfach mal waschen, dann sind die Dinger wahrscheinlich wieder gut.
Wahrscheinlich brauche ich gar keine neue.
High IQ Chat wieder, ich sehe es schon hier.
Massive.
Big Brain.
Was war das?
Habt ihr es auch gehört, Chat?
Lauwarmes Wasser, bisschen milde Seife.
Ja.
Probiere ich mal aus.
Ich wasche das mal.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich gar nicht notwendig, dass ich neue Polster kaufe.
Ja.
Sonntags Team-Messages.
Wir haben noch ganz schön viele Videos offen.
Ist diese Woche irgendwas Interessantes passiert?
Lasst mal kurz gucken.
Github.
Trends.
Oh, ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Ob es irgendwie neue Issues, Antworten oder sonst was gibt.
Ja.
Ach guck mal, der hat geantwortet.
Was hat er denn geantwortet?
Okay.
Der hat zugemacht.
Nice.
Okay.
Ja, was gibt es denn für Github Trends?
Github Trends.
Was haben wir denn?
Lass mal gucken.
Gucken wir doch ab und zu mal.
Lass mal schauen, was die Woche getrendet ist.
Vielleicht ist irgendwas Spannendes dabei.
Memos.
Open Source Self Hosted Memo Hub.
Knowledge Management.
Okay.
Die 50.000 Notizen App, oder wie?
Sieht aus wie Mac OS X.
Sieht aus wie Mac OS Only, wenn ich mir das anschaue.
Demo Horst.
Was horstet der denn?
Und was soll es überhaupt sein?
Live Demo.
Okay.
Zeig her.
Äh.
Was bin ich sehend?
Sign in.
Okay.
Was passiert jetzt?
Legt der jetzt eine neue Instanz an unter der?
Ah ja.
Okay.
Es ist.
Ah.
Es ist eine Notizen Anwendung.
Na zum Glück hat hier keiner irgendwelche Bubas gepostet und ich wäre jetzt gebannt
worden.
Man weiß ja nie, was da drin passiert.
Das mache ich jetzt auch zu, weil ich weiß, es lockt sich jetzt irgendeiner ein und postet
irgendein Pornbild.
Einfach nur, damit ich es im Stream aus Versehen zeige.
Access Point.
Das schmale Access Point.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Nice.
Also irgendeine für Teams Notiz Verwaltung.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit man das braucht.
So.
Naja.
Ja da hat er mal was draufgetragen.
Braucht ehrlich gesagt.
Aber gut.
Scheint ja gut anzukommen auf ShitHub.
So.
Was ist denn sonst noch.
Cheat Punkt SHR.
Das habe ich mal ausprobiert.
Das verstehe ich.
Den.
Reiz daran.
Nicht.
Moment.
Ein.
Ein Neues.
Source Control System.
Also quasi ein Git Konkurrent.
Oder wie in Rust.
Naja.
Es ist in Rust.
Blazingly Fast und Written in Rust.
Dann ist es ja schon mal prinzipiell gut geeignet, um auf Hacker-News gepostet zu werden.
Ist das dieser Fork von...
Wie heißt das andere?
Mercurial?
Mercurial oder irgendwie so?
Wie hieß das denn?
Das da?
Ist das der Facebook-Fork davon?
Ich habe irgendwo mal gelesen, Facebook hätte das geforkt oder so.
Ah ja, hier.
Lul, da steht es doch.
Moin GamerXD.
Okay, weil das von Facebook ist, ist das natürlich dann Rust und Blazingly Fast und ganz toll und alle müssen es verwenden.
Ich habe bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt...
Also es gibt ja viele Sachen, wo ich halt benutze und mir denke so...
Ich benutze es halt so, weil es nicht besser ist.
Es gibt so NPM oder so ein Beispiel.
Oder LibreOffice oder...
Es gibt viele Sachen, wo ich mir denke, ja, ich benutze die halt manchmal, weil man sie benutzen muss.
Nicht, weil sie so geil sind, sondern weil es halt so das Beste ist, was man so benutzen kann aktuell.
Wenn es was Neueres gäbe, was Besseres, würde ich auch das benutzen.
Aber bei Git hatte ich bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nie irgendwie das Bedürfnis, großartig was anderes zu nehmen.
Nee, Microsoft Office suckt.
Ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ich benutze LibreOffice eigentlich auch so gut wie nicht.
Das Einzige, wozu ich es verwende, ist ab und zu mal eine Rechnung als PDF exportieren.
Und das liegt auch nur daran, weil ich bisher zu faul war, das irgendwie in Markdown zu machen.
Okay.
IPTV.
Collection of Publicly Available IPTV Channels.
Okay, das heißt, wenn man nur mit öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendern auskommt, kann man das alles da drüber gucken.
Also ich gehe mal nicht von aus, dass es dort die privaten...
Also ich gucke eh kein Fernsehen mehr.
Also mir ist das eh wurscht.
Ich gucke weder irgendwie ProSieben RTL und sowas, noch gucke ich irgendwie großartig.
Großartig.
ARD, ZDF.
Gucke manchmal vielleicht irgendwelche Ausschnitte auf YouTube von irgendwelchen Sendungen.
Okay.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen bin ich eigentlich schon seit Jahren, man könnte fast sagen Jahrzehnten, fernsehfrei.
Also ich glaube, ich gucke seit 2005 oder so nicht mehr regelmäßig Fernsehen.
Ich will es nicht, dass es jetzt so viel YouTube-Content gibt.
Twitch.
Und die letzten, ja, einige Jahre.
Jetzt auch schon VOD, also Video-on-Demand-Streaming-Seiten von Amazon bis Netflix.
Also Fernseh...
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht, aber mir ist Fernseh eigentlich gar nicht mehr angesagt.
Also normales Fernsehgucken.
Somit aufnehmen.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, als man früher Sachen aufgenommen hat?
Dann muss man die Werbung überspulen und solche Dinger.
Ja.
Okay, das ist Flipper.
Ich habe keine Ahnung...
Was ist Flipper Zero?
Das ist wieder so ein Projekt, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, was es ist.
Flipper Zero.
Was ist Flipper Zero?
Ah, ah, Krypto-Zeug.
Was?
Ich habe...
Okay, jetzt mal ernsthaft, Leute.
Ich habe jetzt die Projektseite gesehen.
Ich habe absolut nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was ich hier überhaupt sehe.
Was ist das?
Ist das eine Kryptowährung?
Ist es Flipper, weil es ein komischer Delfin ist?
Oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Was ist...
Was ist Flipper...
Darf man danach googeln?
Flipper Zero ist ein tragbares Tamagotchi-ähnliches Multifunktions...
Okay, damit hätte ich...
Damit hätte ich gar nicht gerechnet.
Ich dachte, das hat irgendwas mit Kryptowährungen zu tun.
Aber nee, das ist wohl bloß Donations für den Typ.
Ach so.
Ach, das ist quasi, wo man so Sachen wie...
Nee, ist es nicht.
Ich dachte, das ist sowas, wo man Autoschlüssel weiterleiten kann und sowas.
So Wireless-Karten.
Autoschlüssel.
Na doch, Text, Fernbedienung digital, Zugabschlüssel.
Okay, das ist quasi...
Wenn man...
Wenn man wie der Lockpicking-Lawyer sein will, aber digital.
Okay, verstehe.
Das ist aber ein gutes Projekt hier.
Ich habe zwar keine Ahnung bis jetzt gehabt, was es ist,
aber es klingt vor allem noch am sinnvollsten.
Whisper CPP.
Okay.
Machine Learning für C++.
Warum will man sich das frei will?
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich, weil manches anderes zu lahm ist.
Beziehungsweise Integration.
oftmals schwierig. Aber okay,
warum nicht?
Novo,
Open Source Notification Plattform.
Ja, wahrscheinlich
wieder für nicht außer iOS.
Für alles außer iOS.
Wollen wir wetten? Für alles außer iOS.
Kacke.
iOS? Ach nee,
das ist quasi nur so ein Meta-Framework
für unterschiedliche Notification-Services.
Ach so, okay.
Ja, weil Notifications
funktionieren ja auf iOS nicht so
gescheit, wenn man die
nicht quasi
über Apple schicken
will und wenn man die
nicht per Native-App machen will.
Also zum Beispiel Notifications
für eine PWA ist,
soweit ich weiß, unter iOS nicht möglich.
Unter Android
ist das seit vier Jahren oder so schon.
Vier, fünf Jahre schon kein Problem mehr.
Unify Package Manager.
Okay, das ist was für Mac.
Machine Learning Zeug.
Ja,
eine Swift-App, sag ich ja.
Ja, aber du kannst, kannst du,
okay, das ist die Frage.
Kannst du eine PWA machen,
die mit Firebase connected
und Notifications da drüber schickt?
Also die normalen Web-Notifications
kann iOS auf jeden Fall nicht.
Sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben?
Ne, nein.
Da?
Fuck.
Da.
Type-Save-Router-Building
bla bla bla bla.
Okay, das wäre so ein Ding, wo ich gar nicht wüsste, wozu ich das...
es brauchen würde, okay.
Aber ich bin halt auch nicht
im TypeScript-Frontend-Game,
dass ich mich da groß auskennen würde.
Go to Social.
Fast, fun, active
Pub-Server.
Powered by Go. Ganz wichtig.
Es ist nicht written in Rust, aber es ist powered by Go.
Das ist das nächstbeste Ding, was es gibt.
Was ist das überhaupt?
Fast, fun, activity Pub-Server.
Powerful and dangerous
Goblin... Was?
Was bin ich... Was ist das überhaupt?
Das ist... Ah, quasi Twitter-Self.
Self-hosted Twitter.
Nun ja.
Na gut.
Warum nicht?
Machine-Learning-Zeug.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Nginx-Config-Generator.
Okay.
Das ist gar nicht mal übel.
Wenn es viele...
also kompliziertere
Settings unterstützt.
Wenn es die komplizierteren Settings
unterstützt, ist es gar nicht schlecht.
Weil, ich meine, Nginx, die Nginx-Config
ist jetzt zwar gar nicht... ist nicht so abartig
wie eine Apache-Config oder sowas, aber auch
immerhin schon nicht so einfach.
Okay, jetzt soll man hier irgendwas generieren und dann
sagt man was? Und wie generatet
man das jetzt? Ach hier, hier ist
meine generatete Config.
Das ist eigentlich eine
coole Sache.
Ja.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht
schlecht. Mich wundert, dass noch keiner...
da ein Web-Interface für gebaut hat.
Es gibt ja diesen Nginx-Proxy-Manager.
Da kannst du aber die Sachen,
die sich jetzt nicht um Zertifikate und
Reverse-Proxy drehen, eigentlich auch nur von Hand
über das Web-Interface eintragen. Gut, braucht
man ja auch ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich. Ich meine,
wie oft ändert sich auf einem Server so eine
Nginx-Config? Eigentlich gar nicht.
Die baust du für den Server beziehungsweise
für den Dienst oder was auch immer da drauf ist, und dann bleibt
die statisch. Und wenn, hast du es meistens eh über irgendeine
Config-Management-System oder ganz davor als eigene
Kiste. Also, ja, eigentlich ja, gut, dann habe ich
mir eigentlich selbst beantwortet, warum da noch
einer keinen Web-Interface für gebaut hat.
Man braucht es einfach nicht.
Golang LRU.
Ein Golang... Leute, ich kann euch sogar, ich kann euch
sogar sagen, wofür die Abkürzung steht.
LRU ist Last Recently Used.
Also sprich, das, was zuletzt... Also im Prinzip sowas hier.
Notepad.
So was hier.
Das ist quasi eine Last Recently Used Liste.
Nur, dass halt die Sachen, die zuletzt benutzt wurden,
gecached werden anscheinend.
Ist es Last oder ist es Least?
Ist es Last, ne?
Least wäre ja bescheuert.
Ist es Least?
Fuck!
Naja, komm.
Am längsten nicht verwendet.
Okay, okay, es ist Least Recently Used.
Last Recently Used.
Der war ein ganzes Abkürzungszeug.
Kann man sich schon mal vertun.
Chat, Chat.
Wusstet ihr das
oder habt ihr auch nachgeguckt?
50-50 Chance, ja.
So, was haben wir hier?
Scrap-Time-DB.
Written in Rust, dann ist alles gut.
Das würde gar keinen Sinn machen.
Ja, scheint schon.
Was wird hier gecrept?
Open Source Cloud Native Distrib...
Alter, mehr Sachen bitte schön zusammen.
Open Source Cloud Native Distributed
Time-Series-Database.
Scrap-Time-DB.
Ach, Moment, ich dachte, es ist ein Tool,
um Time-DB zu durchsuchen.
Das ist die Datenbank, oder was?
Next Generation Hybrid
Time-Series-Analytics-Processing-Database
in the Cloud.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, Leute.
Ich hoffe, euch ist jetzt allen klar,
was das macht.
Oder obviously.
Also ich glaube, jetzt...
Cringe, wer jetzt nicht versteht,
um was es da geht.
Written in Rust.
Leute, seriously.
Ich werde jetzt gar nicht haten auf dem Projekt.
Auf dem Projekt rumhaten.
Ich kenn's nicht.
Aber wenn der erste und wichtigste Punkt
bei einem Projekt ist,
dass es Written in Rust ist,
dann ist es meistens
nicht,
weil das Projekt sinnvoll ist,
sondern weil irgendwie einer mal wieder
was in Rust neu,
das Rad neu erfinden wollte.
Okay, mit Webseiten ist hier schon mal nicht allzu...
What?
Okay, warum immer dieses Rendern gerade kaputt war.
Okay, Stonks.
Für Stonks ist das gut.
Gut, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Time-Series-Database.
Ja, das hab ich verstanden.
Aber ansonsten, warum man das verwenden sollte,
ich weiß es nicht.
Ganz einfach, ich warte einfach,
bis Fireship ein Video drüber macht.
Dann weiß ich Bescheid, was es ist.
Scalability, Analytical Capabilities,
Efficiency,
Elasticity.
Das kann er dann mal aussprechen, Alter.
Elasticity?
Okay.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar, wofür ich das brauchen würde,
aber gut.
Crap-Time-DB.
Rust benutzen ja gar nicht mal so viele.
Rust ist einfach nur in
Open-Source-Kreisen und in...
bei für neue Projekte
sehr beliebt.
Insgesamt ist die Usage von Rust gar nicht so hoch.
Und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich glaube auch nie,
dass Rust so eine...
15 Sprache wird, die man einfach für alles
jederzeit so verwenden will.
Rust ist echt nicht ohne.
Also Rust ist ziemlich kompliziert.
Rust ist auch sehr komplex.
Und...
Es hat seine Daseinsberechtigung, ja.
Gerade für Software, wo du halt...
Performance brauchst plus
eben so eine gewisse Sicherheit,
dass du...
Gut, ich meine, du kannst es in Rust auch
unsafe bauen.
Du kannst in Rust auch im Zweifelsfall
auf Array-Elemente zugreifen,
die es nicht gibt.
Und dann muss Rust nach wie vor, wenn es nicht
im Vorfeld weiß, irgendeinen Runtime-Check machen.
Aber du kannst halt mit Rust von vornherein
viele Fehler,
die zu Sicherheitsproblemen führen könnten,
irgendwelche Overflows
oder ähnliche Sachen halt von vornherein ausschließen.
Das hat ja schon seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Aber so für die 0815-Anwendung glaube ich nicht,
dass Rust jemals so die...
die Standardsprache werden wird.
Überlegt euch mal, dass 0815
eine interne Zeiterfassungstool zum Beispiel.
Warum alles in der Welt sollte man das in Rust programmieren?
Das Backend.
Außer man will sich das Leben schwer machen
und fünfmal länger brauchen als irgendjemand,
der es in Java, C-Sharp, Python, Go oder sonst was macht.
Ja gut, man kann sagen, unsere Zeiterfassung
ist blazingly fast written in Rust,
aber das wird wahrscheinlich den Chef noch interessieren,
aber den Abteilungsleiter drum drüber schon nicht mehr,
wenn es fünfmal länger dauert.
Okay, was haben wir noch?
Flatbuffers.
Memory Efficient Serialization Library.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich nicht verstehe?
Warum serialisiert man überhaupt in C++ was?
Man kann es einfach zu Bytes casten
und in eine Datei schreiben und dann wieder da rausladen.
Würdest du sagen, man sollte Go lernen?
Ja, natürlich kommt es immer drauf an, was du machen willst.
Natürlich kommt es immer ein bisschen drauf an, was du machen willst.
Um des Lernens Willens und
ein bisschen Übersicht zu haben, ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Wenn du jetzt vielleicht sogar noch ein Projekt im Hinterkopf hast,
wo du sagst, da wird sich das für eignen.
Ja, warum nicht?
Aber wenn du ein spezielles Projekt machen willst,
würde ich eh das nehmen, was dafür am besten geeignet ist.
Es macht jetzt keinen Sinn, eine Webseite zu bauen
und die irgendwie halb in Go zu machen und dann als Web Assembly zu kompilieren,
nur dass es im Browser verwenden kannst, kannst du einfach mit JavaScript machen.
Aber so insgesamt kann man das auch machen.
Aber so insgesamt ist Go Lernen schon sinnvoll.
Go ist eines der gehyptesten Sprachen seit den letzten Jahren schon,
eines der verbreiteten Sprachen und gerade so im Cloud Umfeld ist sehr vieles an Tools.
Ja, von das ganze Docker Kubernetes Zeug bis Terraform und sonst was.
Das ist alles, also sehr, sehr vieles ist in Go.
Das schadet nicht.
Generell schadet es eigentlich so gut wie keine Programmiersprache, sich anzugucken.
Ja, vielleicht außer C++.
C++ ist das.
Das Einzige, wo ich sagen würde Leute, spart, spart euch, wenn es nicht unbedingt notwendig ist.
Give it a go, genau.
Ansonsten ist alles sinnvoll.
Auch Swift kann sich das ja durchaus mal angucken.
Also wenn man, wenn man sich vier, vier, fünf Sprachen aussuchen könnte.
Würde ich sagen, auf jeden Fall JavaScript.
Kommt sich dran vorbei, JavaScript Go.
Diesmal ist gar kein Python Projekt.
Dabei das würde ich mir nämlich auch Ruby.
Python so.
Das würde ich, das würde ich mir pauschal schon mal angucken, das nicht verkehrt.
Python JavaScript Go.
Dann sowas wie C Sharp und Java eventuell noch, weil das eben im Enterprise Umfeld.
Nach wie vor nicht nur sehr beliebt ist, sondern weiterhin beliebt bleiben wird und was die Sharp angeht auch eher noch beliebter wird auch aktuell und die letzten Jahre schon.
Tja, und als fünftes kann man sich dann irgendwas abgedrehtes raussuchen.
Können wir nicht TypeScript sagen?
Nee, zum Einstieg nicht TypeScript.
Muss man sich nicht mit beschäftigen am Anfang.
Wenn man einfach ein bisschen Webseiten basteln will und so die die Basics lernen möchte, muss man sich ja nicht mit TypeScript auseinandersetzen.
Ich mache bis heute so gut wie nichts in TypeScript.
Ich bin nicht, ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Frontend Programmierer, aber wir haben ja schon ein paar Frontend Sachen gemacht im Stream.
Bisher war das immer JavaScript.
Ich habe mir aber überlegt, ob wir nicht demnächst mal ein bisschen TypeScript lernen sollten wieder.
Weil ich habe bei Hacker News letztens, letztens ist auch gut, ist auch schon wieder ein paar Monate her.
Ich habe letztens bei Hacker News einen Blogartikel gefunden, da hat irgendwie einer eine Regex Engine rein im TypeScript Type System gebaut.
Die kann wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht alles oder nicht so krass viel.
Sie matcht anscheinend das eine oder andere.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie er das gemacht hat, geschweige denn, warum das überhaupt möglich ist.
Aber ich weiß, dass das in anderen Sprachen auch schon gemacht wurde.
Also in Ruby, in Ruby hat das glaube ich auch schon mal einer hingebracht, dass er, nee, in Ruby war es umgedreht.
In Ruby war es umgedreht, sorry Leute.
In Ruby war es umgedreht.
In Ruby hat jemand in der Ruby Regex Engine eine Programmiersprache gebaut.
Die so Basics.
Die so Basics Sachen konnte, wie, wie, wie, Schleifen und, und sowas.
Schleifen und, und Ausgabe und so.
Da hat quasi eine Programmiersprache in Regex gebaut.
Ja.
Da habe ich auch gedacht, was ist mit den Leuten verkehrt.
Videovorschlag.
In sieben Tagen zum Pro Gamer, das haben wir uns letztens angeguckt schon.
Wie genau gehst du voran, wenn du eine Programmiersprache lernst?
Ja, meistens liegt das bei mir daran, weil ich irgendwas machen will und dann feststelle, ah, das würde sich jetzt besonders gut dafür eignen.
Zum Beispiel.
Weil es dafür eine super Library gibt, die quasi konkurrenzlos gut ist.
Zum Beispiel Go, wenn man Sachen mit WebRTC machen will auf Serverseite.
WebRTC ist ja eigentlich was, was komplett für Browser gedacht ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel Videokonferenzen im Browser und, und Chat, also Sprache und sowas, geht ja eigentlich komplett alles über WebRTC heutzutage.
Aber wenn man jetzt beispielsweise WebRTC nicht im Browser machen will, sondern vielleicht mit einem Server Backend,
und dem Browser, dann braucht man irgendeine gute WebRTC-Library und da ist tatsächlich Go die Sprache mit der besten WebRTC-Library.
Misch mit diesem Ding hier.
Das kann so gut wie alles, was man braucht, WebRTC-technisch, hat nicht umsonst 10.000 Sterne und es ist sinnvoll, sinnvoll zu programmieren damit.
Und dann würde ich mir in dem Fall, wenn ich damit was machen will, Go angucken.
Weil es halt das ist, was ich vorhabe zu machen und es die beste Library dafür gibt.
Ansonsten, ehrlich gesagt, gucke ich mir als erstes mal ein paar Tutorials an.
Gucke ich mal, ob es irgendwelche so Getting Started Sachen gibt, mal so drüber scrollen.
Und dann ist das Beste, einfach anfangen.
Anfangen, sobald man feststellt, oh Mist, jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie es geht, googeln.
Weitermachen, googeln.
Also im Prinzip 80% googeln.
Oder bingen oder duckduggoen oder was gibt es denn sonst noch so?
Leck gerade.
Was ist denn, was ist denn noch so für Suchmaschinen, die aktuell, jaun, ne, ne, ne, ne, wirklich nicht.
Wirklich nicht.
Gibt es sonst noch, mein früher gab es noch Alta Vista und, und Fireball und solche Sachen, aber Startpage, Ask, Ask.com gab es früher noch und sowas.
Weiß nicht, ob das Zeug überhaupt noch irgendjemand verwendet.
Also Yahoo ist wahrscheinlich in Japan noch beliebt.
Ich habe nie verstanden, warum Leute Yahoo verwenden.
Welche Ausbildung würdest du empfehlen, um in IT einzusteigen?
Oder reicht es, wenn ich mir selber Sachen beibringe?
Naja, wenn du dir ein paar Sachen selber beigebracht hast, so.
Ob das reicht dann, dass sich da für jemand einstellt, weiß ich nicht.
Also die einfachste Variante, also je nachdem, wenn du auch was vorzuweisen hast, warum nicht.
Aber so nach dem Motto, ich habe mal irgendwie einen Python Udemy Kurs gemacht, ich würde da.
Ich meine, wobei auf der anderen Seite aktuell ist der Mangel an...
An Leuten so groß, stellen alle es ein.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, also das Beste, was du an Ausbildung machen kannst, ist nach wie vor, gibt ja nichts anderes.
Du kannst Fachinformatiker Systemintegration lernen oder Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung.
Oder einen der neuen Fachinformatiker, ich habe aber schon wieder vergessen, wie es heißt.
Fachinformatiker Netzwerk.
Wie heißen diese neuen?
Wie heißen diese Dinger?
Bübübübüb, was?
Okay.
Okay, es gibt jetzt nämlich noch Daten- und Prozessanalyse und digitale Vernetzung.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie Ausbildungsplätze dafür gesehen.
Ja, genau.
Richtig.
Letztendlich kommt es darauf an, wo du es machst, ja.
KI-Kunst mit Arte.
Na gut, wenn ich schon Gebühren bezahle.
Web.de.
Ach, das gibt es ja auch noch.
Ja, stimmt ja.
Das ist aber doch bestimmt gar keine eigene Suche, Web.de, oder?
Das ist doch bestimmt irgendwelche, unter der Haube benutzen die Google oder so.
Das kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an, wo man seine Ausbildung macht.
In was es, in welche Richtung es geht.
Aber ich habe jetzt bei meiner Jobsuche gelernt, so was wie Systemadministrator ist outdated.
So was nennt sich heute Linux-Engineer.
Äh, ich habe mir ein bisschen rumgeguckt.
Und, äh, Linux-Engineer ist angesagt jetzt.
Oder DevOps-Engineer, oder Cloud-Engineer, habe ich auch schon gesagt, Cloud-Engineer.
So, jetzt haben wir uns angeguckt, was in GitHub trendet und festgestellt.
Ist nichts dabei, was ich unbedingt mir angucken muss.
Das interessiert mich, was es ist.
Aber, ja, ich wüsste jetzt nicht wozu.
Alles klar.
Easy.
Was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Habe ich schon irgendwas vergessen?
Haha, dann seid ihr richtig oldschool.
Naja, nee, das gibt es schon immer noch.
Aber vermehrt, vermehrt heißt das heutzutage XYZ-Engineer.
Ach, das kommt darauf an, was die Firma damit macht.
Das ist doch alles nicht festgeschrieben.
Also anhand der Jobbezeichnung kannst du ja heutzutage eh nur sehr grob, sehr grob, da erkennen, was du eigentlich wirklich machen wirst.
Deswegen ist es gut, wenn die Stellenanzeigen ein bisschen ausführlicher sind.
Wenn die Aufgabengebiete drinstehen.
Weil rein anhand des Titels kann das, ich meine, es konnte früher schon alles sein, aber jetzt auch.
Gerade in der IT, du suchst, die suchen irgendeinen Job, du guckst dir den Titel an und denkst dir, du weißt, was passiert.
Wir wollen lieber was ganz anderes.
Babbel, dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscriptions.
Oder wie es mein Englischlehrer früher übersetzt hat, danke für das Subscribieren.
Der hat ja ernsthaft Subscription mit Subscribieren übersetzt.
Aber gut, der war auch ein Jahr vor Rente.
Der hat sowas wie YouTube und sowas damals noch nicht mitbekommen.
Obwohl es das auch schon gab.
Ich meine, Berufsschule war 2007.
YouTube gibt es seit 2005, ja?
Genau.
Du bist Systems Engineers, siehst du?
Macht sich auch besser, wenn man Engineer ist.
Auto-Aiming, das haben wir, glaube ich, sogar schon mal geguckt.
Das ist schon ein bisschen älter.
So, was können wir uns denn mal anschauen?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Sony, oh.
Wollen wir uns, komm, wir lassen uns eine Runde Level-Capture-Baiten.
Sony says Battlefield can't compete.
Naja, da hat Sony ganz schön lange dafür gebraucht, um das festzustellen.
Aber, mal ganz im Ernst, die haben es halt selbst verkackt.
Okay, komm, wir lassen uns eine Runde Level-Capture-Baiten.
Eine Runde Level-Capture-Baiten.
Was?
Battlefield?
Nein, das hätte ich jetzt ja nie gedacht.
Behind Call of Duty.
Modern Warfare.
Hat der, hat der gerade gesagt Battlefield 4?
Moment, ich muss mal kurz, äh.
Moment, wo habe ich denn hier meinen Pro-Process-Explorer?
Irgendwie ist mein Rechner etwas laggy gerade.
Was laggt hier rum?
Nix?
Okay, nice.
Chat, wer von euch ist es?
Wegen wem laggt mein Rechner?
Was ist hier los?
Du pinkst gerade, ja?
Dann mach mal Pink.
Ping aus.
Endmap aus, Ping aus, Traceroute aus.
Es peaked in Season 3.
Ja gut, es war auch nicht schwierig zu peaken.
So.
Also, auf geht's.
Level-Cap.
Battlefield 4?
Bin interessiert in 10 Jahre altes Game.
Ja, nachdem das letzte Mass Effect ja so doll war.
Ja.
So.
Soviel was es am Leben noch nicht passiert hat.
Auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt fehlt es auch noch.
Natürlich.
Ist richtig.
Du hast es ja erwähnt.
Und das heißt es gibt es auch noch ein paar Teile.
Du musst dich ganz ehrlich sagen, dass es 10 Jahre ohne Bildung klingt,
da brauche ich aber die 1.
Ach Quatsch, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesagt, die wären blöd, wenn sie das machen.
Ja, das stimmt. Dein Satz verkackt.
Ja, wohin habe ich denn?
Okay, ist das aggressive, wenn man einfach sagt, die haben 400 verkauft und ihr habt nur 88 verkauft?
Also, ist das schon aggressive?
Oder warum ist das aggressive?
Scheint ja so zu sein, oder?
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Ey, die wollen den Kempel ja verkaufen, Warzone selbst ist ja free-to-play.
Every weekend will feature the game's single player or just the multiplayer, as both Warzone and the new DMZ-Extraction-Modes are already free-to-play.
Not only would this pull many players who are still on the fence about buying Modern Warfare 2, but it'll also bite into Battlefield 2042's player base.
Wie findest du das? Ist das Werbung? Ist das deine Seite? Ist das 5-Head-High-IQ-Werbung? Das will ich jetzt wissen, bevor ich das einklinge.
Nein? Okay.
Zeig mal her. Ich glaub dir mal, dass es nicht deine Seite ist.
Zeig mal her. Weiterbildung zum Programmierer.
Die Frage ist nicht so sehr, ob man dann irgendwie so einen Kurs gemacht hat oder nicht, sondern ob das irgendjemand interessiert, also ob es deine Chancen wirklich verbessert.
Gibt ja bei den Amis auch viele Bootcamps, das ist in Deutschland jetzt eher weniger verbreitet.
Als Quereinsteiger in drei bis fünf Monaten zu einem gefragten Webprogrammierer.
Anschließend ersten Job in der Frage.
Frontend, Backend, Fullstack, In.
In neun Monaten machst du alles.
Alles klar.
Die Digitalisierung ist jetzt auch in Deutschland voll angekommen.
Auf dem Jobmarkt suchen gerade überall tolle Unternehmen.
Da hab ich so meine Zweifel, ob das alles tolle Unternehmen sind, aber okay.
Das stimmt. Es ist insofern schon richtig.
Die suchen alle händeringend Leute.
Wer ist denn das?
Den Kerl hab ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen auf YouTube, glaub ich.
Den hab ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Okay, bla bla bla.
Den Kerl hab ich auch schon mal irgendwo auf YouTube gesehen.
Äh, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob es jemanden am Ende interessiert, ob du so einen Kurs gemacht hast oder nicht.
Müsst man sich jetzt mal im Detail angucken.
Kann ich jetzt so pauschal nichts zu sagen.
So, mal gucken, was Sony weitererzählt.
...which is also hosting free-to-play weekends in December.
Ubisofts beloved Splinter Cell series is being adapted to radio.
The BBC...
Ich hab mich grad aus Versehen angeklickt.
Ich hab mich grad selbst...
Ich hab mich grad selbst erschreckt, warum einmal Voice-Sounds hier kommen.
Ich war noch auf dem falschen Bildschirm.
...the Britains largest radio broadcaster is adapting the game series into a drama show on their Radio 4 station.
Ey, Leute, Leute, wie wär's, wenn die mal wieder ein neues Splinter Cell-Game machen, was was taugt?
Ganz einfach so.
Und vielleicht ohne Türme erobern?
The series will start on the 2nd...
Das muss man ja bei Ubisoft mittlerweile dabei sagen, weil in jedem Ubisoft-Game werden Türme erobert.
...in the 2nd of December and features an original story.
It'll follow the series' protagonist, Sam Fisher,
as he attempts to recruit and train the next generation of national security agents.
The cast includes Adonis Anthony, Daisy Head, Will Poulter and others.
The series will run for 8 30-minute episodes, arriving every Friday.
CD Projekt Red has dropped the first trailer for the Witcher 3's next-gen upgrade.
Kommt das auch auf den PC?
At first glance, the trailer doesn't look drastically...
Kommt das auch auf den PC oder ist PC schon immer next-gen?
...better, but there's more to it.
Raytracing will greatly improve the world's lighting.
And this update includes various performance enhancements.
The trailer also showed off new content coming to the game...
Und muss man das neu kaufen, wenn man es schon hat, auf dem PC wahrscheinlich, oder?
...fired by the Netflix series.
Ich frage jetzt, ob die ganzen Mods dann funktionieren auch.
A native photo mode will also be added, which will surely show off the title's refined graphics and lighting.
The update is set to go live for free on the 14th of December for all owners of the game.
Based on a new job listing...
Ah, free! Free for all owners.
Ich glaube, dann werde ich mir auch mal wieder eine Runde Witcher 2 geben.
...ist schon immer noch eines der nicesten RPGs, die es so gibt.
...games studios appears to be developing a AAA third-person action RPG PC title.
The recently announced Netflix studio based in Los Angeles is headed up by a former Overwatch executive producer.
The job listing shows that the studio is searching for directors, art directors, producers and more for its new PC game.
The new title appears to be powered by Unreal Engine 5 and will feature the storytelling worthy of a TV show, according to the list.
Things are obviously very early in the development process, so this RPG could be a long way off.
Though it'll be interesting to see what Netflix can bring to the gaming world.
The Callisto Protocol is an upcoming sci-fi horror set to release early next month.
Das ist doch das von den ehemaligen, oder von einigen der ehemaligen Dead Space Leuten, oder?
Das habe ich, glaube ich, noch so im Hinterkopf.
...behind it, Striking Distance, is helmed by Glenn Schofield, who previously co-created the Dead Space series.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Ich dachte, es ist ein Singleplayer-Game, warum hat es einen Season Pass?
...die Callisto Protocol hat diese Woche eine Aufmerksamkeit gemacht, weil es um die Veränderung des Saisons Pass geht.
Wie auf der Theme-Page bezeichnet, wird der Saisons Pass...
Ich dachte, es ist ein Singleplayer-Game, warum hat es einen Saisons Pass?
...für vier Komponenten, die Outer Way Skin Collection, zusätzliche Story DLC, eine Riot-Bundle, die einen neuen Wave-Base-Modus und einen Permadeath-Modus bezieht.
Jedoch begannen die Fans zu fragen, was, wenn sie das Saisons Pass entdecken, auch eine zusätzliche 25 neue Todes- und Verletzungen geben würde.
13 für den spielbaren Charakter und 12 für die Enemies.
Mit viel von der Marketing-Fokussierung der neuen Gore-Engine und den Todes-Animationen,
waren die Fans überrascht, dass viele dieser Animationen hinter einem Paywall liegen.
Schofield hat Twitter gewechselt, um...
Alter!
Willst du jetzt ein DLC kaufen, dass dein Charakter wenigstens...
ordentlich stirbt, oder was?
...die Narrative.
Er hat den Fans geäußert, dass die 25 Todes-Animationen nicht vom Basis-Game abgehängt werden.
Stattdessen werden sie spezifisch erschaffen,
für das Saisons Pass.
Er sagt, die Devs werden nur die neuen Animationen im neuen Jahr erstellen.
Overwatch 2 Season 2 wird am 6. Dezember starten.
Und Blizzard hat bestätigt, dass sie Details über die neuen Inhalte über die kommenden Tage veröffentlichen werden.
Die Dinge werden dieses Wochenende mit einem neuen Gameplay-Trailer...
Ich bin mal echt gespannt. Ich spiele zwar gerade kein Overwatch 2 und ich habe es auch nicht vor.
Da hat mich Blizzard zu fettig gemacht, den Overwatch 1.
Ich beobachte das aber und ich bin mal gespannt,
ob es Blizzard diesmal schafft, für nennenswerte Zeit ordentlich Content zu liefern.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das aktuell läuft.
Und das Spiel annehmbar zu patchen.
Am Anfang von Overwatch hatten die ja riesen Probleme.
Da haben die ja teilweise Monate für gebraucht.
Es kam ein Patch raus...
...es kam ein Patch raus.
Irgendwas war total broken und kaputt.
Und das hat dann erst mal drei Monate gedauert.
Wo man sich damit rumschlagen musste.
Da sind sie mittlerweile besser geworden.
Aber immer noch nicht im Bereich...
...also, als ich mir das das letzte Mal angeguckt habe...
...aber immer noch nicht in dem Bereich, wie ich mir das gewünscht hätte.
Weil ganz im Ernst...
...eigentlich sollte man doch darauf gucken, dass man, wenn man Spiele heutzutage rausbringt,
Multiplayer-Spiele, die einen gewissen Competitive-Aspekt haben,
dass man das möglichst schnell patchen kann.
Schnell heißt, innerhalb von ein paar Tagen.
Am besten, dass man gleich, und sogar ich meinen Call of Duty kriege,
...am besten, dass man gleich, und sogar ich meinen Call of Duty kriege,
große Glitches geben. Ich denke mal, das können sie
mittlerweile.
Ansonsten
ist halt die Frage, ob es Blizzard diesmal schafft,
mehr als
ab und zu
mal einen Comic
und ab und zu mal
irgendwie eine Map
zu liefern. Das ist halt
nichts, was die Leute langfristig schockt.
Außerdem
bin ich eh gespannt, wann endlich mal ihr
Singleplayer-Modus kommt.
Und Overwatch 2
wurde ja ursprünglich angekündigt,
also der
Haupt-Aufhänger
damals, um
Overwatch 2 anzukündigen,
war ja der
Singleplayer-Modus.
Oder besser gesagt,
dieser
PvE-Modus. Nicht wirklich Singleplayer-Modus,
der PvE-Modus ist es ja eher.
Und davon hat
man jetzt erstaunlich wenig gesehen in letzter
Zeit. Weiß gar nicht, wann das kommt.
OW2-PvE-Release-Date.
Release-Date.
2023. Ja, siehste.
Dann ist halt die nächste Frage,
seriously, warum, und das habe ich
bis heute nicht so genau verstanden, warum genau
ist es eigentlich
Overwatch 2?
Ich meine,
ja, man sieht, dass sich grafisch ein bisschen
was getan hat. Ja, die Helden
sehen teilweise ein bisschen detaillierter aus.
Aber ich meine, jetzt nicht so wirklich
wahnsinnig großer Unterschied. Also,
wenn du jetzt...
Wenn du jemandem was zeigst
auf Overwatch 1 und Overwatch 2,
hey, ja, also ich glaube nicht,
dass so die meisten Leute direkt den
Unterschied erkennen können. Also,
es ist ja nichts drin. Es sind irgendwie
vier, fünf neue Helden oder so
gibt es jetzt insgesamt. Ich habe gestern erst wieder
einen neuen Ankündigungs-Trailer für einen Held gesehen.
Sie haben
alte Maps, die haben sie,
2CP-Maps haben sie entfernt.
Und haben
dafür diesen neuen, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie der heißt, dieser, dieser,
Schiebemodus eingeführt.
So.
Und ansonsten, mein, viel hat sich da nicht getan.
Es ist jetzt Free-to-Play.
Und es hat eine 2 im Namen. Also, im Prinzip
könnte man sagen, es war ein
Free-to-Play-Relaunch
mit einer 2 im Titel, dass es sich
abgrenzt vom ersten, obwohl es eigentlich
das erste ist.
Ist damit Version 1 eingestampft?
Ja. Version 1 gibt's nicht mehr.
Ja.
Das sind noch die besten Videos, die es gibt.
Ein Gameplay-Trailer und Content-Roadmap
wird am November 29. live gespielt werden,
folgend dem Erleuchten des neuen Maps
des 2. Debs haben T...
Irgendwie muss ich auf Overwatch immer noch...
Erinnert sich noch jemand an den Tracer-Hintern-Skandal
am Anfang von Overwatch?
Das war auch so ein Ding, Alter.
Wo sie sich alle aufgeregt haben
und ich mir gedacht habe, Mensch, habt ihr Probleme?
Also, wer sich ja nicht mehr dran erinnern kann.
Tracer hatte eine Pose, eine Victory-Pose in dem Spiel, wo man sie von hinten gesehen hat, wo dann quasi der Tracer-Pobbes schön in der Mitte war und das Zentrum des Bildes war Tracers Hintern.
Da gab es damals eine riesen Aufregung, achso und irgendjemand hat herausgefunden, das wäre angeblich eine ehemalige Playboy-Pose gewesen und das ist ja ganz furchtbar schrecklich und da wurde sich damals wahnsinnig drüber aufgeregt.
Und daraufhin hat Blizzard das deaktiviert und entfernt, weil sie ja nicht wollten, dass sich irgendjemand unsafe oder so fühlt in dem Game, bloß das damals, das fand ich dann eigentlich, ja.
Schon irgendwie ein bisschen jebaited von Blizzard, die haben dann eine andere Tracer-Pose reingemacht, wo nicht ganz so viel Fokus auf dem Hintern von Tracer gelegt wurde und da hat dann jemand herausgefunden, das wäre angeblich auch eine Playboy-Pose, aber das haben sie dann nicht wieder entfernt.
Generell Overwatch hatte schon gerade am Anfang einige Kontroversen, zum Beispiel wo es diesen...
...Comic gab, wo man gesehen hat, dass Tracer eine Freundin hat und wo sich dann die Leute auch sogar darüber aufgeregt haben, die hätten sich mal lieber um ihre Mitarbeiter kümmern sollen, die sich unsafe fühlen, korrekt, das stimmt wohl, ja und zumindest wurde sich dann darüber auch aufgeregt, dass Tracer lesbisch ist laut diesem Comic, weil...
...und jetzt kommt die bescheuertste Begründung, die ich...
...die ich je gehört habe, weil Tracer ein Charakter ist, der explizit für das männliche Auge entworfen wurde und deswegen geht das überhaupt nicht und ich habe mir damals schon gedacht, okay, hätten sie jetzt Saria genommen und hätten gesagt, die ist lesbisch, dann wären die gleichen Leute gekommen, hätten sich aufgeregt, russische Bodybuilder, Klischees, was auch immer und hätten sich darüber aufgeregt.
Du kannst es den Leuten einfach nicht.
...recht machen, was das angeht.
Das ist unglaublich bescheuert.
Okay, next.
...different Nerfs and Busts für certain Characters, so it'll be interesting to see how the game can be changed up for Season 2.
Deep Silver will be hosting a showcase for their upcoming zombie action RPG, Dead Eye...
Haben wir irgendwann mal die Zombie-Games hinter uns? Seit wie vielen Jahren gibt es Zombie-Survival-Games jetzt?
15 Jahre? Und es hört nicht auf?
...Island 2 on the 6th of December.
Dead Island 2 hat einen sehr rockigen Entwicklung, der seit 2014 von Entwickler zu Entwickler übernommen worden ist.
Aber es scheint jetzt, als ob das Spiel im April nächstes Jahr endlich auf die Läufe kommt.
Es wurde ursprünglich vorgeschlagen, dass es im Februar startet, aber es wurde zurückgepusht, dass die Devs es noch öffnen, bevor es live läuft.
Die kommende Showcase verspricht Gore, Action und viel neuer Gameplay.
Es wird auch die neuen Features und Mechaniken des Spiels erneuern.
Es hat so lange gedauert, dass die Fans ehrgein sind, um zu sehen, wie das Spiel aussehen wird.
...und auch, dass die Fans ehrgein sind, um zu sehen, wie das Spiel aussehen wird.
Jucht mich überhaupt gar nicht!
Oh, Moment, ich habe noch die Musik an.
Ach Forge! Ist es jetzt? Ist es soweit?
...Fans haben sich beschäftigt, ihre eigenen Campen und Content zu trainieren, mit dem Einsatz der sauberen Forge Mode.
...und wir sehen die öffentliche Meinung, die sich immer mehr positiv ändert.
Der nächste Content Drop wird Saison 3 sein.
Die Startdate vom 7. März 2023 sollte mit einem bisschen Salz auf die Evolution gelegt werden.
By the way, erinnert euch mal daran!
wurde von battlefield 20 42 entwicklern angeführt als grund warum battlefield 20 42 so schlecht
abgeschnitten hat kann man sich das wirklich vorstellen also wie unkreativ kann man denn
bitteschön bei der ausredenfindung sein und wie weit hergeholt wie weit hergeholt möchten sie ihre
ausreden haben ja es hat sich bereits in der vergangenheit gedelayt leaks online aber haben
fans excited the league suggest three new maps will be added with sie sind auch die
klammer schiefen ihre map a high altitude base and another map that looks very similar to the
content already found in the game season 3 will also introduce a new dmr type weapon called the
m392 bandit and a new smoke grenade gadget star citizens developers reveal the new concept ship
this week as part of the intergalactic aerospace expo ongoing celebration and free fly event the
ship is called the rsi gadget
it has a modular interior that will let you customize its functionality these modules will
include a cargo module a refinery module and even a medical module it'll be bigger than the
already fairly sizable constellation making it one of the larger ships that players can utilize
what we know so far comes from the latest inside star citizen episode which was mostly a concept
preview of the ship today we're gonna find out even more details including the price for the
concept ship spiel jemand von euch regelmäßig ich mein star citizen ist ja auch ein bisschen
immer ein game was du seit einer weile spielen kannst und auch wohl recht viel so zumindest
exploring technisch recht viel umfang hat mich spricht sich an und ich weiß nicht so auch der
zustand von so einem halbfertigen sich permanent für immer in entwicklung befindlichen game spricht
mich jetzt nicht so an aber ich weiß dass es genug leute gibt dies die spielen spiel jemand von euch
hat wir beim tour next start today let us know what you think of sony's comments about battlefields
Ich muss noch sagen, wo wir gerade bei
Spielen sind, die nie fertig werden.
Mein Star Citizen kannst du immerhin noch spielen
und
es scheint ja wohl auch genug Leute zu geben,
denen das gefällt. Eine Sache
muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Ich habe ja früher ganz viel
Dark Age of Camelot gespielt.
Das war ein MMO aus
2001.
Das ist das Spiel bis mit heute, finde ich,
das was das beste
MMO PvP aller Zeiten
hatte. Gerade weil du drei verschiedene
Fraktionen hattest und so ist es halt
nicht langweilig geworden. War da nicht
so nach dem Motto hier, eine Seite
hat irgendwie 80% der Spieler
wie manche WoW-Server oder sowas.
Das war eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Vor ein paar Jahren hat
der ehemalige Chef
des Studios, die damals Dark Age of
Camelot gemacht haben,
einen Nachfolger oder
ein Alternativprodukt angekündigt.
Nämlich das hier.
So.
Das Spiel wurde angekündigt.
oder so.
Und es gibt bis heute
keine
richtige Alpha und keine richtige Beta.
Es gibt so interne Playtests
und sowas. Und ich habe das damals
gebackt für glaube ich 200 Euro
oder sowas für Early Access
Zugang auf Kickstarter.
Und
worauf ich raus will ist folgendes.
Ich habe mich selten so verarscht
gefühlt wie von denen.
Weil jetzt passt mal auf.
Ähm, ich hoffe man kann sich das anzeigen lassen.
Passt mal auf. Wir reden hier von einem Spiel,
das
über 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist.
Und jetzt guckt euch mal den
letzten Newsletter an.
Concept Arts.
Wir reden über ein Spiel, was
10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist.
Concept Arts.
Sowas postet man in seinem Kickstarter-Projekt,
um zu zeigen, guckt mal hier, so können wir es uns vorstellen.
Concept Arts. So was postet man in seinem Kickstarter-Projekt, um zu zeigen, guckt mal hier, so können wir es uns vorstellen.
Concept Arts. So was postet man in seinem Kickstarter-Projekt, um zu zeigen, guckt mal hier, so können wir es uns zeigen.
Concept Arts. Okay, ich mein, diesmal sieht man da tatsächlich sogar ein bisschen ingame aus.
10 Jahre. 10 Jahre Entwicklung.
Wo ist denn der letzte Newsletter, worüber ich mich so lustig gemacht habe, letztens?
Hier, ich sag mal hier.
Concept Arts. Concept Arts. Concept Arts.
So. Und im letzten Newsletter.
In einem der anderen Newsletters.
Concept Arts. Concept Arts. Leute, das Spiel ist
10-11 Jahre in Entwicklung.
Und wo sie
den Vogel abgeschossen haben letztens.
außerdem sieht die Grafik für das, für, für, für 10 Jahre immer noch, wo sie wirklich, wo sie wirklich den, den Vogel abgeschossen haben, letztens war, haben sie ein Newsletter gepostet, so angeblich furchtbar neue Errungenschaften, und da haben sie tatsächlich drei Seiten drüber geschrieben, für ein Spiel, was über 10 Jahre in Entwicklung ist, und am Ende haben sie drei neue Bilder gepostet von Crafting-Werkzeugen, Crafting-Werkzeugen, Mann,
und ich dachte mir so, Alter, das Spiel ist 10 Jahre in Entwicklung, was juckt's mich, wie eure scheiß Crafting-Werkzeuge aussehen, warum sind die überhaupt noch nicht im Spiel drin, nach 10 Jahren, also das ist so heftig verkackt, also ich hab mir selten, ich kann mir selten so verarscht vor, von, von einem Projekt als von Camelot Unchained,
eine Sache, wo ich mir noch ähnlich verarscht vorkomme, ähnlich verarscht vorkam,
war die selbstreinigende Jeans, die ich auch für 200, 300 Euro gebackt habe, die aber niemals ausgeliefert wurde, Alter, Leute, hier, guckt, selbstreinigende Jeans, ich war so blöd, dass ich das geglaubt habe, ja, selbstreinigende Jeans, aber die gibt es bis heute nicht, Lieferung 2016, ja, ist klar, ganz bestimmt, ich hab bis heute nix gekriegt, niemand hat bis heute irgendwas gekriegt,
nach 5 Jahren, ist klar, Fly,
Crafting-Buttons, die kommen jetzt bestimmt nach 5 Jahren zu dir und sagen, ah, nee, nach 6 Jahren, 6,5 Jahre, kommen die bestimmt zu dir und sagen, ah, ja, ja, okay, jetzt gibt es einen Refund, ganz bestimmt,
Keck, wait, Alter, die haben mich richtig gescampt, Mann,
benutzen immer noch die Dark Engine, nicht direkt, also, da muss man, da muss man ein bisschen, letztendlich ist aber auch egal, ja, aber ich, ich versuche dir das mal zu beantworten, also,
die Dark Engine war, äh, Gamebüro oder wie das hieß, irgendeine alte Version davon, Gamebrio, ja, viele MMOs damals wurden, äh, darin erstellt, sogar Spiele wie Fallout benutzten, benutzten eine Variante davon,
das war damals recht beliebt, so, das ist, das ist quasi die Engine, die in der Dark auch entwickelt wurde und für Camelot Unchained wollten sie ja eine eigene Engine bauen,
die super Massenschlachten und sowas kann, wobei sie unter der Haube, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch wieder diesen Crap hier verwenden, deswegen sieht das Spiel auch aus wie von 2014,
mal ganz davon abgesehen, das Spiel sieht ja aktuell auch gar nicht aus, weil außer Concept Art gibt es ja nichts, kann man sowas bei Kickstarter melden, ja, aber Kickstarter kann ja da auch nicht viel machen,
ja, das Geld haben sie ja, haben sie, ist ja weitergeleitet worden an die und es muss jedem klar sein,
dass Kickstarter Risiko ist, also sollte, also das Einzige, was sein kann, ist, wenn die vorsätzlich die Leute gescampt haben, dass es dann irgendeine Sammelklage gibt, oftmals in den USA,
falls irgendjemand dieses Desaster mit Chronicles of Elyria oder wie das hieß, mitbekommen hat, da ist ja auch so gelaufen, dass die gesagt haben, Alter, die haben uns vorsätzlich gescampt,
die haben Millionenweise gescampt.
und es gibt so viele Leute, die sagen, die haben Geld eingesammelt und hatten nie wirklich vor, ein Spiel zu entwickeln, na, dann gibt es vielleicht rechtlich Probleme, aber ansonsten ist Kickstarter Risiko, ich meine, wenn irgendjemand einsammelt, wenn jemand 50.000 Euro einsammelt und sagt, er will davon Produkt XY bauen, er versucht es, er gibt sich Mühe, es klappt nicht, aus welchen Gründen, ja, er hat sich verkalkuliert, es ist gar nicht möglich, was auch immer, dann ist es letztendlich das Risiko dessen, dass du da gebackt hast, das ist halt Bestandteil der Plattform irgendwo und ich finde auch nicht, dass man jemand sperren kann, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen, das ist halt ein bisschen,
was man sagen sollte von Kickstarter, wenn er wirklich alles versucht hat, das Projekt auf die Beine zu stellen und es ist dann am Ende halt an irgendwelchen Sachen gescheitert, das kann ja sogar was sein, wo er es verkackt hat, wie gesagt, er hat sich verkalkuliert mit der Zeit, mit was es kostet, vielleicht fällt ihm erst beim Bauen auf, okay, serienmäßig kann man sowas gar nicht fertigen, was auch immer, das ist halt Risiko, das ist ja da nicht mutwillig die Leute gescampt, die hatten ja wirklich vor, das zu bauen,
es gibt allerdings ein paar Projekte, wo ich mir auch denke, die sind von Anfang an eigentlich schon gar nicht möglich, zum Beispiel gab es ja dieses Projekt, erinnert sich noch jemand an dieses Wasser in der Wüste Projekt, wie war das, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das hieß, wie hieß das, wie hieß das, dieses, dieses, ach Gott, ich war auch noch nie in einer Wüste, ja,
äh, das war nicht alles, Water Seer, Water Seer, genau, das war nicht, ah, das war gar nicht auf Kickstarter, okay, das war auf Indiegogo, ah, das gibt es, gibt es gar nicht mehr, okay, ach, das, das ist jetzt was anderes, oder, ja, zumindest, die wollten quasi in einer Wüste Trinkwasser für alle fördern, so, und da hat man sich eigentlich von Anfang an denken können, das kann nicht funktionieren,
das wird eben, das, das, das ist, ergibt, ergibt, das ganze Konzept ergibt keinen Sinn, so, und, das sind so Sachen, wo ich mir dann denke, ey, wer da backt, weiß nicht, der will irgendwie gescampt werden, oder, es gab doch auch mal dieses andere Projekt, da weiß ich aber gar nicht, ob es ein Kickstarter Projekt war, oder ob das eines dieser super neuen Startups ist, es gab doch mal dieses, ähm, Karussellding, mit dem besonders günstig,
äh,
Dinger in die Erde,
Zeitumlaufbahnen geschossen werden sollen, ich, ich, wie hieß das denn, die, die haben sich aufgespielt wie das neue SpaceX, Spin Launch, chat, wie ihr das wisst, Spin Launch, genau, die, die meine ich, Spin Launch, und das sind auch so Dinger, die, die guckst du dir an, und denkst dir so, okay, ich frage mich allen Ernstes, wie soll das funktionieren,
also, denen ihre Idee ist folgendes, die, es gibt ja nicht einmal gescheit Bilder, also, die wollen quasi so eine, so eine Karussell bauen, und das soll gedreht werden, und dann soll das quasi so schnell gedreht werden, dass es dann in die Erdumlaufbahn geschossen kann, geschossen werden kann, also, da gibt, da gibt es so viele Probleme, wo ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass es funktioniert,
also, erstens ist halt Luft,
Widerstand, immer noch ziemlich doof,
und das nächste ist,
wie unglaublich schnell sich der Kram drehen
müsste, dass es das schnell
genug beschleunigen könnte, ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert, ich meine,
ich lasse mich da gerne eines Besseren belehren,
aber das sind so Dinger,
wenn ich die sehe, habe ich so meine
Zweifel, ob das
überhaupt funktionieren kann,
gescheit, und mal davon abgesehen,
warum sollte
man es drehen, warum nicht einfach
mit irgendwelchen Magneten beschleunigen,
oder sowas, also, warum muss es sich, warum muss
es sich gerade drehen, also,
da habe ich wirklich meine Zweifel,
da habe ich, da habe ich wirklich meine Zweifel, ob das
was ist, was funktionieren kann,
und da denke ich mir immer, okay, wenn da jetzt einer sein
Geld reinhaut, ist das
dann noch
Zukunftsvision, oder ist das einfach
Realität ausgeblendet,
ja, genau, und du musst es auch noch
richtig releasen, dass es da
dorthin kommt, wo du es haben willst, also,
ich habe echt
große Zweifel,
dass das realistisch ist,
unter der Test funktioniert,
ja, Moment, das funktioniert doch auch
anders, oder, 100
Kilo, na, da viel Spaß,
das funktioniert,
ich habe da wirklich
große Zweifel, ob das tut,
aber hey, ich meine, vielleicht bin ich einfach nur nicht
Zukunfts
Visionär genug
dafür, aber gut, es ist
auch egal, es war kein Kickstarter-Projekt, ich habe das
durcheinander gebracht, Moment,
Moment, es geht nicht,
darum, irgendwas zu probieren,
es geht darum, was zu probieren, was
irgendwie realistisch erscheint,
und ich habe da meine Zweifel, ob
das realistisch ist,
es sagt jetzt ja auch keiner, guck mal,
es gibt genug Unternehmen, die sagen,
wir bauen einen Weltraumaufzug,
gab es die letzten Jahre immer mal wieder,
und, wer hat bisher einen Weltraumaufzug
gebaut? Keiner,
wir haben noch nicht mal Material, um sinnvollerweise
sowas zu bauen, geschweige denn,
haben wir das Problem gelöst, wie weit
musst du es auf der anderen Seite rausbauen,
dass es funktioniert? Nichtsdestotrotz
hält es nicht Leute davon ab,
Unternehmen zu gründen, die angeblich
einen Weltraumaufzug bauen wollen,
macht es aber nicht realistischer,
realistisch ist
zum Beispiel, dass wir mal wieder,
dass wir eine Mondbasis bauen, oder sowas,
das ist realistisch, da haben wir die Technologie dafür,
das kostet Geld as fuck,
das ist sicherlich nicht ungefährlich, das geht,
aber es sind so ein paar andere Dinge, wo ich mir denke,
ja, okay,
but why, also, das ist
total außerhalb,
der Möglichkeiten aktuell sowas zu bauen,
das hat keiner gemacht,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so weit
außerhalb der Vorstellungskraft, dass man
eine Rakete recycelbar bauen könnte,
dass einer morgen, in den nächsten
paar Jahren, irgendwie einen Weltraumaufzug
baut, ist
nochmal ein ganz anderes Kaliber.
Vor allem ist das Problem,
dass du den ganzen Krempel ja auf der anderen Seite
auch noch unglaublich weit nach außen
bauen müsstest, und mit dem
Material, was wir aktuell haben,
müsstest du das Ganze,
auch so kegelförmig
bauen, das muss nach oben dann immer breiter
werden, also war ganz merkwürdiges,
ganz merkwürdiges Zeug.
Ja, 46 Kilo-Bomb.
Das hat er übrigens nie gesagt, dass 46
Kilobyte reichen.
640 Kilobyte.
Das ist auch so ein Zitat, was ihm
angedichtet wird.
Ja, ne, das hat er nie gesagt.
Keck.
Ja.
Übrigens noch eine weitere lustige Sache,
ähm, Thema Weltraum,
Luftraumaufzug. Wisst ihr, was da auch unglaublich schwierig
ist? Also, neben ganz den vielen anderen
ungelösten,
ungelösten Probleme,
was da auch schwierig ist, die Stromversorgung.
Du kannst ja nicht
einfach ein Kabel durchlegen.
Das wird schlicht und ergreifend alles zu schwer
und ist nicht belastbar genug. Also, du kannst
ja nicht einfach Kabels durchlegen, so ohne weiteres.
Oder ja, gut, sag mal.
Macht halt Probleme.
Und, das heißt,
das müsstest du dann irgendwie mit einem Laser machen
oder sowas, ja. Also, sprich, dass du dann
irgendwelche super starken Laser auf der Erde
hast und an dem, an dem
Fahrstuhl hast du dann quasi irgendwelche
Foto,
tja, wie nennen wir das so,
Solarpanels quasi in klein.
Dann laserst du dann da drauf
und
das hat,
da gibt's wirklich enorm viele Probleme.
Aber es gibt trotzdem Unternehmen, die gegründet
wurden die letzten Jahre, kommt immer mal wieder
Neues dabei, die sagen, sie bauen sowas.
Es gibt enorm, enorm viele
Probleme dazu. Wie gesagt,
das ist halt so Sachen, wo ich mir denke, das ist unrealistisch,
sowas in den nächsten paar Jahren
oder Jahrzehnten zu bauen.
Da kann man noch so viele tolle Marketing
Ideen haben.
Es wird wahrscheinlich nix.
Ja, aber nicht das, was sie vorhaben.
Was anderes.
Da kommt vielleicht was bei raus, ja.
So.
Also, was kann man uns als nächstes anschauen?
Zeig mal her. Was haben wir denn hier für spannendes Zeug?
Was heißt spannend? Kecke.
So, das haben wir fertig geguckt.
Genug Level Capture Bait.
Developers share a short video clip
celebrating the series protagonist
Commander Shepard.
Relay Machine.
Play YouTuber.
Ist Shepard am Ende nicht gestorben?
In the game.
They're so detailed.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Okay, also, was haben wir hier zu bieten?
150 Euro.
150 Dollar. Wahrscheinlich eher 200 Euro Nass.
You can actually build.
Naja, das ist kein Ding.
Nass für 150 Dollar oder für 150 Euro zu bauen.
Da kann ich auch was zusammenwursten.
Ohne Platten, versteht sich.
Ob man das dann wirklich betreiben will?
Das stimmt schon.
Ist was anderes.
Wir skippen mal kurz drüber.
Was?
Denkst du, Elon Musk wird in 10 bis 20 Jahren US-Präsident werden?
Weiß gar nicht, ob er da Interesse dran hat.
Genug Hardcore-Fans hätte er wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob es dafür in der Summe genug gibt.
Ach, der ist kein Ami?
Ist er nicht? Echt nicht?
Ja, dann wird das nichts.
Du musst ja, soweit ich weiß,
musst du ja nicht nur Amerikaner sein.
Du musst doch auf dem Festland geboren sein.
Nee, dann wird das nichts.
Dann kannst du es vergessen.
Wie gesagt, du musst, glaube ich, auf dem Festland geboren sein.
Es gibt da irgendwelche komischen Regelungen,
nur wann du US-Präsident werden darfst.
Ja, dann wird das natürlich nichts.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das der Südafrikaner ist.
Wenn es danach geht, bin ich ja auch halber...
Nee, Viertel Südafrikaner.
Viertel Südafrikaner.
Mein Uropa war in Südafrika.
Das war ja wohl damals so eine beliebte Fluchtort für Deutsche.
Südafrika.
Ja.
Liegt.
Es war damals, glaube ich, tatsächlich relativ häufig,
dass Leute so geflüchtet sind nach Südafrika.
Also was heißt geflüchtet?
Also von meinem Uropa weiß ich nur,
das war irgendwie...
Irgendwie so,
dass seine Frau hier, also quasi meine Uroma quasi,
die war schwanger mit meiner Oma.
Und dann ist mein Uropa abgehauen,
als die schwanger war nach Südafrika.
Einfach CU.
Nix wie weg.
Fuck.
Verantwortung, Verpflichtung hier.
Ich muss weg.
Und dann ist er nach Südafrika abgehauen.
XD.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts übersehen an Subscriptions hier.
Einfach CU.
Ja.
Einfach weg.
Gut, mehr weiß ich dazu nix.
Nee, mein Uropa, das war noch vor 2. Weltkrieg und sonst was.
Eine ganze Weile vor 2. Weltkrieg müsste das gewesen sein.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob es...
Lass mal überlegen, ich kann es euch nicht genau sagen,
aber wir können das mal kurz überschlagen.
Also, ich bin 38.
So, meine Mutter hat mich auch ungefähr gekriegt,
so mit 35.
Okay, sagen wir mal mit 40, 40, 80 Jahre.
Die Oma hat sie auch wegen Krieg und allem relativ spät gekriegt.
Also hauen wir da nochmal 35 Jahre drauf.
Also sagen wir mal, rechnen wir mal hoch 120 Jahre.
Und dann noch der Uropa, das müsste es quasi so vor 150 Jahren gewesen sein.
Ungefähr.
Würde ich jetzt mal so sagen.
So in dem Dreh.
Vor 150 Jahren.
Also 2022 minus 150.
1872, kann das sein?
Das kommt einem ja so ewig lang her, Mann.
Ja, aber das kann schon sein.
Dass es 1872 war.
Oder sagen wir mal, gut.
Der Uropa hatte...
Der Uropa hatte ja auch vielleicht, wahrscheinlich nicht zwei Jahre nach Geburt bekommen,
sondern sagen wir mal so vielleicht, vielleicht 1900.
Vielleicht 1900.
Zumindest ist mal nur Uropa abgehauen.
General Slane, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, wie gesagt, ich kann das jetzt natürlich nur raten.
Also ich denke mal, irgendwie so zwischen 1870 und 1910 oder so wird das gewesen sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Also es müsste auf jeden Fall noch vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg gewesen sein.
Und es müsste auch weit, weit vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gewesen sein.
Ah, 1970.
Ja, so in dem Dreh.
Ah, siehste?
Und dann ist er abgehauen nach Südafrika.
Man hat nie wieder was von ihm gehört.
Soweit die Überlieferung zu meinem Uropa, ja.
Keine Ahnung, was da wirklich war.
Ich meine, ich war ja logischerweise nicht dabei.
Okay, also, weiter.
Da gibt es bestimmt noch Grundbesitz in Südafrika, der jetzt mir gehört.
Hey, vielleicht, wer weiß, wer weiß.
Vielleicht bin ich mit Elon Musk verwandt.
Kann alles sein.
Okay.
Also, was baut der denn hier für ein NAS zusammen?
Wir gucken das jetzt nochmal ganz durchgeskippt.
Also.
Oh, da hört, okay.
Resident Sleeper Time.
Ja, das ist ja logisch.
Die Festplatten kannst du in den Preis nicht inkluden.
Das ist, Festplatte allein kostet ja schon 150 Euro.
Also, ne, große.
Ich habe das gemacht, für, meiner Meinung nach, gute Gründe.
Aber, nicht inkludieren, die Kosten der Fahrzeuge, hat viele Leute verärgert.
Also, nach ein bisschen Forschung, Wartezeiten und Trübschützungen, präsentiere ich euch das hier.
Ein 100-
Ja, er hat von Ebay eine alte Kiste gekauft, ja, super.
Ein 150-Dollar-NAS, den du tatsächlich bauen kannst.
Aber, vielleicht solltest du das nicht machen.
Das ist ein paar verschiedene Sachen.
Leute, was ist das?
Ist, ist das der Passwort-Safe von NordVPN?
Leute, ich vertraue ja NordVPN.
NordVPN noch nicht mal, dass sie ein ordentlicher VPN-Service sind.
Ich würde im Leben, im Traum, was, was, was gibt's noch, was gibt's da noch für eine Steigerung von?
Also, niemals im Leben, nicht mal im Traum, würde mir einfallen, meine Passwörter im NordVPN-Passwort-Safe zu speichern.
Und wenn du keinen Passwort-Manager benutzt, dann bist du in ein bisschen Problem.
Glücklicherweise gibt es NordPass.
In keiner Dimension des Multiversums würde es mir einfallen,
meine Passwörter im NordVPN-Passwort-Manager zu speichern.
... Passwort-Manager, created by the same Cyber-Security-Experts that built NordVPN.
Ja, ja.
... and more similar passwords, including random and complex passwords across a large architecture.
... for a few reasons.
Well, really just one reason.
... to other NAS-Devices.
Okay, erzähl mal.
Also, er hat einen alten Rechner von eBay gekauft und an das Zeug eingebaut.
Na geil.
... a little bit at least.
... on Amazon, technically, but are sold from GoHardDrive.
Ultrastar, Hitachi.
Ist doch, oder? Ist doch Hitachi.
... technically, but are sold from GoHardDrive.
Ganze vier Terabyte.
Oh, das geht doch sogar.
... GoHardDrive.
... smart data.
Okay, useless.
Hey, das ist Dings hier.
Ach nee, das ist Open...
Aha, das neue Open Media Vault habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Da sieht er tatsächlich ganz brauchbar aus mittlerweile.
... Open Media Vault.
Booting Open Media Vault from a flash drive isn't necessarily supporting big dusting outside.
With all the big dust bunnies and such out of the case, I replaced the thermal paste...
... runde Wärmeleitpast draufspritzen.
... and reattach the cooler.
The drive's...
Leute, ihr müsst mir jetzt mal, wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich bin ja dabei, mir einen neuen Rechner zusammenzustellen.
Und ich habe mehr oder weniger alles, alles schon, alles schon soweit mir ausgesucht.
Aber ich bin immer noch ein bisschen am überlegen, ob, also da hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab, welches Gehäuse es am Ende wird, ob Luft- oder Wasserkühlung.
Ich hätte ja mal Bock, wirklich mal einen Rechner mit Wasserkühlung zu bauen.
Ich meine, das wird irgendeine All-in-One-Wasserkühlung, nix custom gewurstet das, ja klar, was für Noobs wie mich.
Aber die Sache ist halt die.
Das wird entweder...
... eine 13.900, 13.700.
Nimmt sich ja nicht allzu viel.
Ist Wasserkühlung eigentlich wartungsfrei, wenn du so eine All-in-One nimmst?
Ja, wobei ich da nicht weiß, ich hatte sowas ja noch nie.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, ob man nicht dort auch irgendwie alle paar Jahren was wechseln muss oder so.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Weiß ich nicht.
Die Pumpe ist viel zu laut.
Sagst du das jetzt nur oder hast du das ausprobiert?
Weil ich habe ein paar Tests gelesen.
Zum Beispiel für diese Arctic Cooling Freezer 2 oder so.
Die sind eigentlich relativ leise laut Tests, ja.
Das habe ich auch gelesen und da ist halt auch...
Weißt du das, weil du es selbst hattest oder sagst du das jetzt nur, weil du es in einem Forum gelesen hast?
Ich habe beispielsweise einen Langzeittest gelesen.
Da haben sie glaube ich acht Jahre oder so.
Die Wasserkühlung verbaut gehabt.
Und die ging danach immer noch ganz gut.
Und es gibt sogar Hersteller, die geben dir mittlerweile fünf Jahre Garantie auf ihre Wasserkühlung.
Das heißt, es wäre ziemlich bescheuert, wenn die nach drei bis vier Jahren kaputt geht.
Weil...
Also warum ich überhaupt am überlegen bin, ist folgendes.
Warum ich am überlegen bin, ist folgendes.
Also, wir testen Deutschlands beliebteste Wasserkühlung.
Welche ist denn das?
Ist das Deutschland beliebteste Wasserkühlung?
Ach hier.
Da ist das Ding.
Okay, das können wir uns tatsächlich gleich mal angucken.
Also...
Aha.
Also, die Sache ist halt die.
Wie gesagt, entweder ein 13.900 oder ein 13.700.
Die Sache ist halt die.
Wenn man da jetzt nach...
Wenn man da mit Benchmarks machen will, ja?
Also, wenn ich da irgendwie Signbench, Scenebench, Prime95, Gedöns, Volllast laufen lassen will.
Dann kommen die CPUs quasi immer, auch mit einer Wasserkühlung, ans 100.
Grad Limit.
Die Sache ist nur die, dass das unter realistischen Bedingungen, also bei Spielen zum Beispiel,
oder auch bei Videoeditieren und selbst bei Videorendern, so nicht sein wird.
Das heißt, aus dem Gesichtspunkt reicht eine Luftkühlung eigentlich aus.
Es sei denn...
Also, es kommt auch ein bisschen darauf an, was für ein Powerlimit man im BIOS einstellt.
Es sei denn, man legt Wert...
Auf, ähm...
Irgendwie...
Besonders hohen Boost-Takt.
Weil das macht die CPU ja irgendwie daran fest, wie viel...
Ähm...
Temperaturspielraum sie noch hat.
Also, es könnte sein, dass potenziell die CPU kühler bleibt mit einer Wasserkühlung.
Und dementsprechend länger, schneller hochtakten kann.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob sich der ganze Stress, den man eventuell hat durch eine Wasserkühlung...
Lohnt versus eine Luftkühlung.
Luftkühlung wäre ganz einfach...
Da haue ich wieder Noctua, äh, DH-15 oder, äh, NH-12 oder wie das kleinere heißt, drauf und gut ist.
Ich habe eine umfunktionierte Abstellkammer, das ist richtig.
Theoretisch könnte ich meinen PC da reinstellen, will ich aber nicht.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, die hat ja keine Klimaanlage.
Für alles, was da aktuell drin ist, ist es kein Problem.
Aber wenn ich da meinen Rechner reinhaue, dann wird es zu warm.
Ich meine, die CPU frisst bis zu 300 Watt, die Grafikkarte auch, was auch immer wie viel.
Das wird nix.
Mach so PC-Building.
PC-Building-Stream, ja, mach ich.
Wenn ich mich dann endlich mal dafür entschieden habe, was ich kaufe...
Du kriegst die Wasserkühlung nicht in ein kleines Case.
Für einen 13.900, da brauchst du mindestens 360 Millimeter oder 420 Millimeter, also brauchst du eine große Wasserkühlung.
Und dementsprechend brauchst du auch ein sehr fettes Case.
Du brauchst aber eh ein fettes Case, weil du eine 4090 einbauen musst.
Was sagt denn der Bauer dazu?
Das ist mit der Arctic Liquid.
Kennt sich mit sowas doch aus.
Deutschlands beliebteste Wasserkühlung.
Warum kein 13.600?
Weil ich Performance High End kaufen will.
Das muss ja wieder 5 Jahre halten.
Das ist auch die günstigste AIO, die wir im Test haben.
Kostet ca. 115 Euro aktuell für eine 360er AIO.
Echt sehr, sehr preiswert, muss man sagen.
Von der Montage ist es auf jeden Fall anders als die anderen im Test.
Hier haben wir erstmal links und rechts diese zwei schwarzen Brackets, die wir unten am Pumpenkopf befestigen müssen.
Abhängig davon, welcher Sockel verwendet wird.
Dann haben wir hier die Backplate.
Da kommen Abstandshalter durch.
Die Abstandshalter werden mit O-Ringen von oben gesichert.
Das Ganze kommt dann von unten durchs Mainboard.
Und dann klebt man normalerweise diese Mini-Unterlegscheiben mit DDR5 um die Sockelmontagelöcher außen rum.
Ich persönlich klebe das immer ganz gern auf die Seite von dem Abstandshalter, weil dann habe ich es nicht auf dem Mainboard kleben, wenn ich dann was anderes montieren möchte.
Dann schraubt man das hier rein.
Anschließend noch den Pumpenkopf drauf und dann mit den Schrauben hier fixieren.
Interessant.
Interessanterweise holt sich Arctic Liquid Freezer 2360 erstmal die Spitze im Gaming-Test mit 38,5 Grad Celsius.
Hat der auch Lautstärke irgendwie mit drinne?
Wenn wir allerdings auf Volllast gehen, dann sehen wir, dass die Lüfter einfach nicht genug Drehzahl haben, um mit den anderen AIOs mithalten zu können.
Dafür ist das Ding aber wirklich angenehm leise.
Also mit maximaler Drehzahl 42,6 dB.
Da haben wir mit den anderen ja 10 mehr.
Das ist schon echt ein großer Unterschied.
Dafür ist es sehr, sehr nah an der Silent Loop 2 dran.
Die sehr gute La...
Also 42 dB ist nicht viel.
Es ist aber hörbar auf jeden Fall, ja.
Also 42 dB ist ungefähr so...
So ASMR-Videolautstärke.
Trifft's glaube ich ganz gut.
Wenn einer, wenn einer so hörbar flüstert, würde ich sagen, sind ungefähr 42.
Guck mal mal.
Ja, ja.
Genau.
Soft Whisper.
Okay, 42 ist noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ähm, Dezibel ist ja so eine etwas unintuitive Skalierung.
Also man darf jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass 80 dB doppelt so laut sind wie 40.
Sondern die sind viel, viel, viel, viel, viel lauter als 40.
Ich glaube alle...
So ungefähr alle drei Dezibel das Doppelte.
Oder wie war das?
Ich krieg's, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf.
So aus dem...
Ich glaube, ich glaube, mit einem Daumen gepeilt kann man irgendwie sagen, alle drei doppelt so laut?
Oder nee, wie ist das?
Ach, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mehr hin.
Nee, alle 13?
Alle 13 doppelt so laut?
Ob alle 5 oder 10?
Alle 10?
Wisst ihr?
Chat hat auch keine Ahnung.
Genauso wie ich.
Also, das dürfte, das dürfte ungefähr, wenn ihr ASMR-Videos hört, ungefähr in dieser Lautstärke dürfte dann auch eure...
Na gut, das hängt natürlich davon ab, wie weit ihr aufreißt.
Also, wenn einer flüstert...
Das hört man.
Also, wenn einer hörbar...
Also, wenn einer flüstert, so dass er will, dass er verstanden wird.
Also, es ist auf jeden Fall hörbar.
Leistung erkauft sich die Liquid Freezer 2A...
Wie war das jetzt hier mit der Lautstärke?
Die sehr gute...
Ups.
Wie war das mit der Lautstärke?
Also, 42, 42...
Also, man hört's auf jeden Fall.
Und man hört's halt immer.
Auch im Desktop-Betrieb.
Das Gute aktuell an meinem Setup ist halt, da ist zwar ein fetter Noctua-Lüfter drauf.
Und wenn ich spiele, dann dreht der auch ein bisschen rauf.
Aber im Desktop-Betrieb höre ich meinen Rechner halt gar nicht.
Ich höre gerade...
Du hörst nichts.
Der ist quasi silent.
Der Noctua dreht ganz leise.
Die Gehäuse-Lüfter drehen ganz leise.
Also, langsam und leise.
Ich höre aktuell quasi nichts.
Nichts.
Der Silent Loop 2 dran.
Die sehr gute Leistung erkauft sich die Liquid Freezer 2 AIO vor allem durch die Dicke des Radiators.
Wir haben hier 35 mm, während wir bei den meisten anderen AIOs nur 25 mm Dicke haben.
Und dementsprechend haben wir hier einfach deutlich mehr Fläche.
Braucht man ein fettes Gehäuse.
Wir machen weiter mit der Pure Loop 2FX.
Wieder von Be Quiet.
Auf den ersten Blick könnte man meinen, das ist ein bisschen ähnlich zur Silent.
Fazit.
Weiter auf Artic Liquid Freezer 2 AIO auf jeden Fall der Gewinner.
Die Temperaturen überzeugen und der Preis ist mit 115€ einfach unschlagbar.
Allerdings müssen wir hier auch erwähnen,
dass durch den dickeren Radiator
die AIO auch mal mit dem Gehäuse kollidieren kann,
wenn ihr da was kleines oder enges habt.
Nee.
Das müsst ihr auf jeden Fall vorher irgendwohin...
Die Deepcool LS 720 ist aus meiner Sicht auf jeden Fall eine Empfehlung wert,
denn sie ist am Ende nur ein wenig schlechter als die Artic Liquid Freezer 2 im Gaming Szenario,
hat aber zusätzlich RGB Lüfter...
RGB-Lüfter und aus meiner Sicht auch den
wichtig, wichtig, wichtig
deutlich ansprechenden Pumpen
beziehungsweise Kühlerkopf und
kostet dafür auch nur 30 Euro mehr.
Die Be Quiet! Silent Dupe 2 und
NZXT Kraken bieten für den
Preis ebenfalls eine sehr solide Leistung
und sind optisch für mich subjektiv betrachtet
auch schöne Alternativen zum
Liquid Freezer 2. Bei den
Be Quiet! IOs sei zusätzlich noch positiv
erwähnt, dass diese die einzigen Modelle
hier im Test waren, die einen vernickelnden
Boden haben. Damit rein theoretisch auch
kompatibel zu Flüssigmetall sind
und definitiv korrosionsbeständiger.
Also, was ich definitiv
nicht mehr machen werde, ist meine CPU
Köpfen. Das habe ich mit meinem aktuellen gemacht.
Da habe ich geschwitzt, so wie
selten beim Technik, also beim
Basteln mit Technik. Also ich
habe ja aktuell einen 8700K
Ist schon ein bisschen her.
Ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Und ich hatte einen der ersten, ich bin an
einen der ersten CPUs in Deutschland
gekommen, damals.
Also ich habe die ganz normal bezahlt. Ich habe die nicht
irgendwie gesponsert bekommen. Also die haben das natürlich noch
früher gehabt. Aber ich hatte quasi eine der
ersten normal lieferbaren CPUs
in Deutschland. Das heißt, hätte ich
die kaputt gemacht beim Köpfen, ich
hätte vier, fünf Wochen warten müssen, bis
ich überhaupt wieder eine CPU bekommen hätte.
Ich habe wirklich geschwitzt damals
und außerdem wären es auch irgendwie 450 Euro
gewesen, die ich in den Sand gesetzt hätte.
Ich habe wirklich geschwitzt beim
Köpfen. Glaubt es mir, Alter.
CPU. Ich habe das
sogar aufgenommen. Ich wollte das damals
ein Video zu machen, aber es hat mir
qualitativ da nicht gefallen.
Da habe ich einen blöden Winkel aufgenommen.
Also das war wirklich nicht ohne.
Wenn man den Preis betrachtet, ergeben
MSI Core Liquid, Aorus Waterforce
und Corsair H150i
Capellix auf jeden Fall wenig Sinn.
Dafür bieten diese extra Features wie
LCD-Display, IQ-Integration oder
generell Möglichkeiten, euer System
an gegebenenfalls vorhandene Komponenten
anzupassen. Sei das jetzt zum Beispiel Corsair.
Ich meine, es sieht cool aus. Brauchen tut es keiner.
Wer guckt da schon rein? Bei MSI das entsprechende
Mainboard oder auch bei Gigabyte entsprechend.
Das Mainboard oder Grafikkarte. Die Ergebnisse
hier unter Volllast zeigen jetzt noch auf,
welches Kühlungspotenzial in den Lüftern...
Ja, okay. Unter Volllast?
Wie laut sind denn die im Desktop-Betrieb?
Das ist ja das, was
mich interessiert. Weil ganz
im Ernst. 42
Dezibel unter... Ah, ne Moment.
Moment, Moment. Das ist jetzt unter...
Ha, ich habe mich verguckt. Aber
unter Volllast? Das ist ja nix.
Da hast du eh einen Kopfhörer auf.
Und selbst wenn, dann stört
dich das nicht.
Wie hast du den geköpft? Mit dem Tool vom Bauer?
Ne, mit einem Konkurrenztool.
Ich wollte mir ursprünglich
eigentlich das Tool vom Bauer kaufen.
Aber das war damals nicht lieferbar.
Da habe ich... Was habe ich denn?
Dr. Delit
CPU hieß das, glaube ich.
So ein Ding.
So ein Ding habe ich mir damals gekauft.
Habe ich letztens erst weggeschmissen. Braucht man ja nicht mehr.
Painless and easy.
So ein Teil hatte ich
damals. Habe ich
letztens erst
entsorgt.
Und dann Flüssigmetall drunter.
Direkt auf die
CPU. War es painless und easy?
Im Prinzip
ja. War es.
Ich habe halt übelst geschwitzt dabei, weil du halt
bei jedem Knacken und so gedacht hast, du machst
deine CPU kaputt.
Ich kann euch sagen, es ist ein ganz komisches Gefühl,
wenn ihr an eurer CPU rumschraubt
und es macht Knackgeräusche.
Da denkt ihr erstmal, fuck, das geht kaputt.
Aber das ist normal.
Das ist normal,
weil
das ist ja festgeklebt.
Das reißt halt ab.
Und dann macht es immer
Was genau bringt das Köpf in der CPU?
Also, prinzipiell erst einmal gar nichts.
Also nicht einfach machen,
weil ich jetzt irgendwie was gesagt habe.
Das war in Zeiten, wo Intel
gespart hat bei den CPUs.
Der 8700K
der hatte
Zwischenmoment. Mal gucken, ob es
da ein Bild irgendwie von gibt.
Also, normalerweise machst du deinen
Lüfter ja hier oben drauf.
Ja, ja, hier sieht man es.
Hier sieht man es schön.
Also normalerweise ist das hier ist ja normalerweise der Deckel.
Von deiner CPU.
Quasi so der Heat Spreader für den, für den, für den Kühler.
Da kommt da kommt oben drauf, kommt ein CPU Kühler drauf.
So, Intel hat jetzt gespart.
Intel hat das nämlich hier folgendermaßen gemacht.
Das hier ist ja quasi die die Oberseite von der von der CPU.
Also wenn du hier was kaputt machst, ist dann die CPU kaputt.
Oh, ich hab deine CPU im Arsch.
Die hat die Oberseite der CPU um den Heatspreader,
Die hat die Oberseite der CPU und den Heatspreader,
nur mit Wärmeleit-Paste miteinander verklebt,
also intern in der CPU selber, also in diesem In dieser 156 00やりだいやだ
kompletnen Paket da,
war das dann hier Wärmeleitpaste drauf
und die War dann halt hier oben mit verpappt.
Das heißt, du hast quasi intern von der CPU
die Hitze schon über Wärmeleitpaste
passte, an den Heatspreader weitergegeben
und von dort dann nochmal Wärmeleit
passte an den Kühlkörper und dann ging es weiter.
So.
Wenn man diesen Heatspreader
entfernt hat, ja hier sieht man
ja auch, wie es funktioniert, ja.
Ja, ja, ist gut. Wenn man den Heatspreader
entfernt hat, dann kommt man direkt
an die Oberseite von der CPU dran,
dann hat man dort so Flüssigmetall
Legierung drauf gemacht
und dann musste man aufpassen,
Obacht,
entweder
haben ganz verrückte Leute
direkt hier drauf
ihren Kühlkörper gemacht,
da musste man aber aufpassen, dass du es
auf gar keinen Fall verkanntest, weil
ansonsten ist deine CPU kaputt
oder, was ich gemacht hab,
ich hab hier Flüssigmetall
dazwischen gemacht,
hab den Heatspreader wieder oben drauf gemacht, also was
ich im Prinzip gemacht hab, ist
ich hab die billige Wärmeleitpaste,
die Intel hier dazwischen hatte,
ausgetauscht durch Flüssigmetall
Legierung.
Was deutlich besser die Wärme geleitet,
hat oder leitet zwischen
der CPU und dem Heatspreader
und dann da oben drauf den Kühler.
Hat den Vorteil,
du machst nicht so leicht was kaputt.
Wenn du direkt hier drauf
den Kühler machst, gerade wenn es
noch Kupfer unten hat, Kupfer hat Probleme
oftmals mit der Legierung,
dass es dann anfängt
gröselig zu werden mit den Jahren.
Kühlt theoretisch
noch ein bisschen besser,
aber ist,
auch viel größer die Chance, dass du deine
CPU kaputt machst.
So, und das sah dann folgendermaßen aus.
Ja genau, dann sieht man's.
Das hier ist der Heatspreader oben drauf und
dazwischen hat Intel Wärmeleitpaste gemacht.
So, damals wohlgemerkt bei aktuellen CPUs.
Bei aktuellen CPUs ist das verlötet.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Also man muss das nicht mehr köpfen.
Aktuell hier dazwischen ist keine
Wärmeleitpaste mehr bei neuen CPUs, sondern
das ist verlötet.
Das ist also alles gut.
So, mal gucken, ob das zeigt, wie das ist.
Ja, genau.
Und hier die Lösung.
Hier funktioniert das.
Stellt die CPU rein
und benutzt die Kabel um den Lid zu drücken.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, man bekommt den Sound
der knackenden CPU mit.
Die Glu wird sich dann lassen
und ihr könnt die CPU öffnen.
So einfach ist das!
Aber...
Nein, die haben keinen Sound mit aufgenommen.
Leute, hier,
eure CPU knarzt und knackt
und ihr denkt euch, gleich ist sie kaputt.
Öffnet die CPU.
Jetzt, die macht normalerweise, macht der so
und dann ist er halt offen
und du denkst dir halt, oh, jetzt hab ich sie kaputt gemacht.
Ja, das Ab, das Ab,
so einfach
ab geht das auch nicht.
Zumindest bei mir nicht. Ich musste hier unten drunter
noch ab, also ich musste noch
ein bisschen nachhelfen, dass das ab geht.
Ja, das war jetzt eine
ziemliche, ziemliche
blödsinnige Anleitung.
Ich mein, die haben zwei Sekunden das eigentliche
Köpfen der CPU gezeigt. Also, damals
war das sinnvoll, das hat wirklich enorm viel,
Leute, das hat wirklich extrem viel gebracht.
Meine CPU ist danach irgendwie 12, 13 Grad
kühler gewesen als vorher.
Es war ein richtig, es war ein wirklich riesen, oder 15 Grad,
es war ein riesen Unterschied.
Vorher, Prime 95,
direkt
ans Limit geschossen.
Danach konnte ich ihn übertakten,
400 Megahertz, auf, glaub, 5,2.
5,2
Gigahertz in 8700K
und er lief immer noch.
Mit Luftkühlung.
Also, das hat wirklich extrem viel gebracht.
Bei hoher Drehzahl
steckt. Ich muss auch erwähnen, dass bei den kompletten
Tests, sei das jetzt Gaming, oder
auch bei diesen Tests, die Pumpen immer
bei 100% liefen.
Das könnt ihr euch jetzt noch helfen, je nachdem, wofür
ihr eure IEO
auswählen möchtet, beziehungsweise,
wofür ihr das einfach braucht.
Wenn zwischendurch kleine Bencher sind,
dann ist das eigentlich okay.
Das ist nicht irgendwie belastend.
Das ist leise, leises Flüstergeräusch,
während man spielt, ist doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Also, ich tendiere aktuell nämlich tatsächlich
eher zur Wasserkühlung.
Einfach, weil ich schon immer mal eine weiße PC
mit Wasserkühlung jetzt haben wollte.
Ich mein, die ganze Zeit hab ich ja immer gesagt,
gehen wir fort mit Wasserkühlung.
... auswählen möchtet, beziehungsweise, wofür ihr das einfach braucht.
Wenn zwischendurch kleine Bencher sind, dann ist das eigentlich nicht so, dass ihr das einfach braucht.
Wenn zwischendurch kleine Bench-Sessions auch mal geplant sind,
dann würde ich persönlich zur Kraken X73,
Corsair H150i
oder Deepcool LS720 greifen.
Einfach, weil
die Kühlleistung obenhin auch noch da ist
und das Mounting entsprechend
einfach ist, um auch mal entspannt die CPU zu wechseln.
Fairerweise muss man aber trotzdem sagen,
dass die Arctic Liquid Freezer 2
hier auch wieder eine Art Gewinner für sich ist.
Zwar jetzt nicht durch die niedrigsten
Temperaturen, aber wenn man jetzt mal die Temperaturen
betrachtet, in dazu in Relation
die Lüftergeschwindigkeit und
damit auch die Lautstärke,
dann muss ich sagen, spricht das schon für sich.
Abzuraten wäre aus meiner Sicht hier
von der PureLoop 2 FX360
von be quiet, weil das war die einzige...
Ich will keine Custom-Wasserkühlung.
Ich will irgendwas, was ich mir komplett selber bauen kann.
Also wo ich meinen Rechner
selbst zusammenbauen kann und fertig.
... in unserem Test,
die die CPU bei Full-Out,
also mit 260 Watt, nicht
dauerhaft kühlen konnte. Also hier war es so,
dass die CPU auf manchen Kernen so heiß
wurde, dass es sich runtertakten musste.
Insgesamt würde ich sagen, dass gerade die
Gigabyte Waterforce 360
und die MSI Core Liquid 360,
das gilt wahrscheinlich auch für eine Asus AIO,
die ich jetzt nicht im Test hatte.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich persönlich sagen würde, die würde ich jetzt unbedingt
verwenden. Ich sehe, dass man die eigentlich nur
verwendet, wenn man ein System hat, wo
das vom Theme her irgendwie reinpassen
soll. Weil ansonsten, gerade
preis-leistungstechnisch... Also ganz ehrlich,
ob das einheitlich aussieht oder
so in meinem Rechner, ist mir vollkommen egal.
... die AIOs von diesen Herstellern
wahrscheinlich immer die schlechtesten.
An dieser Stelle muss ich auch einmal mal sagen,
Gigabyte, ihr müsst endlich mal eure RGB-Software
in den Griff kriegen. Das ist wirklich absolut
grausam. Also die anderen machen jetzt
auch nicht die beste Software, aber aus meiner Sicht
Gigabyte immer mit Abstand am schlechtesten
bei der RGB-Software. Geht einfach...
Es geht einfach auf die Nerven. Ich sehe halt auch irgendwie
keine Entwicklung bei Gigabyte in der Software
und da muss echt mal endlich mal was
passieren. Dieses Video war jetzt vom
Zeitaufwand her sowieso viel mehr, als ich dachte.
Ich habe jetzt deswegen nur eine einzelne AIO
und da habe ich mir die Gigabyte AIO
ausgesucht, weil die überraschenderweise,
wenn man sie mal schlecht performt hat,
und die sollte wahrscheinlich besser sein.
Und ich habe das jetzt mal mit dem Contact Frame
von Thermal Greasy, also von uns,
montiert und da sehe ich...
Was zum Teufel ist ein Contact Frame?
Ich dachte dort ist alles dabei,
was man braucht, um es zu montieren
auf der CPU.
Ich weiß, was es ist. Doch, jetzt wo ich
nachdenke, das ist so ein Teil, dass der Druck,
dass der Anpressdruck
gleichmäßiger auf dem Mainboard verteilt ist
oder sowas. Das ist so quasi...
Da kannst du dann quasi
dein Drumherum, wo du normalerweise
den Lüfter reinklippst,
kannst du austauschen durch irgendwas,
wo du ein bisschen mehr Druck auf die CPU kriegst.
Glaube ich.
Sowas ist das, glaube ich.
Verbesserung von 5,5 Grad.
Jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass wahrscheinlich
auch andere, wahrscheinlich die meisten
von den AIOs, auch eine Verbesserung
sehen würden. Also man sieht auf jeden Fall
nochmal einen Shift nach links. Etwas niedrigere
Temperaturen, da kann man nochmal was
rausholen. Es ist jetzt
für mich vom Zeitaufwand her einfach zu viel
jetzt nochmal jede AIO da einzubauen,
nochmal jede mit einem Contact Frame und dann zu
checken, was da verbesserungsmäßig drin ist.
Aber es sei auf jeden Fall erwähnt,
dass auf jeden Fall diese Plattform
nicht gerade positiv für
diverse Kühler ist, was die Kühlleistung betrifft.
Ansonsten muss man auch ganz klar
festhalten, dass es eigentlich egal ist,
welche wir hier verwenden. Wenn ihr das nur zum
Zocken verwendet, ist es komplett egal, weil
guckt euch die Temperaturen an, die wir bei dem
12900KS hatten.
Wir reden da um Temperaturen im Schnitt,
wie gesagt im Schnitt ist auch wichtig zu sagen,
von 40 Grad Celsius. Da auch wichtig,
wir haben ja den Durchschnitt über
alle Kerne gebildet. Das heißt alle 8
P-Cores, alle 8 E-Cores.
Bedeutet natürlich auch, dass da gern mal
ein P-Core dabei ist, der dann seine 60, 70
Grad hat und wird natürlich im Durchschnitt dann
von den anderen Kernen runtergezogen.
Aber trotzdem sind es Temperaturen, die halt
absolut traumhaft sind für alle CPUs
in dieser Region. Also zum Zocken,
komplett egal welche ihr da benutzt, könnt ihr
eigentlich frei auswählen, weil es ist eure
CPU einfach egal, ob die jetzt da
5, 6 Grad kühler läuft.
Ich glaube, ich hole mir dieses Mal wirklich eine
Wasserkühlung. Ich habe da irgendwie mal Bock drauf.
Das ist glaube ich trotzdem mal interessant.
Und der Rechner wird eh teuer as fuck.
Da kann man das auch machen.
Und nochmal der Hinweis,
auch wenn wir jetzt für dieses Video...
Ist Twitch, was? Ist Twitch
am abkacken? Sekunde.
Oh!
Vodafone!
Was ist hier los?
Was ist hier los, Vodafone?
Was gibt es hier?
Anzeige ist raus.
No!
No! God, please, no! No!
Crynet, danke schön für den Sub.
Wuselmeister, danke für den
Sub hier. Ganz übersehen.
Ja, was machen wir denn da jetzt?
Wenn Vodafone wieder am rumkacken ist
hier. Was ist das?
Guckt euch das mal an! 65%
Framedrops!
What the fuck! Vodafone, please!
Ich mach mal kurz den
Speedtest auf der anderen Seite. Mal kurz
gucken, was da wieder
hier im Argen ist.
Da geht gar nichts!
Der Speedtest funktioniert richtig.
Vodafone war wieder richtig am reinscheißen
grad. Nicht mal
der Speedtest funktioniert, Mann.
Speedtest is broken.
Na toll.
Erstklassig funktioniert
ja wieder alles. Einfach
60% weniger Framedrops.
High IQ Chat wieder.
Dann sind's halt nur noch 65% von weniger.
Der Speedtest, der geht einfach nicht.
Also Vodafone ist komplett
im Arsch grade.
Okay, jetzt wird's ein bisschen besser. Zeig mal.
Ne.
Ne, ne, ne.
No pass.
55%.
Oh, es geht runter, Leute. Es geht runter.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wir sind bloß noch bei
17%.
20%.
Frameloss.
Jetzt geht der Speedtest auch wieder auf der anderen
Seite. Okay, okay.
Leute, was soll ich machen?
Man könnte versuchen, den Twitch-Server
zu wechseln. Aber ich
ich vermute, daran liegt es
nicht. Ja, die hätten auch
ne All-in-One-Wasserkühlung verbauen sollen auf ihren
Switchen.
Okay, okay, okay, okay. Oh,
Leute, Leute.
Postchamp? Postchamp?
Postchamp?
Scheint wieder zu gehen. Guckt mal da.
Geht wieder.
Easy.
Hoffen wir mal, das bleibt so.
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Funktioniert wieder. Sehr schön.
Pog. Also, was können
wir uns als nächstes mal anschauen? Was haben wir hier?
Ja, dann sind wir stehen geblieben.
Das hat ja überhaupt keinen Sinn gemacht, dieses
Bild von ihm. Also,
was heißt keinen Sinn gemacht?
Würde ich nicht bauen.
You have to go back into the
two caddies from...
Hey, ich brauch
keinen Mensch. Was ist das?
Eggdrop from Space.
Viertes auf Trending. Boah.
Da haben wir mal hier richtiges
Hype und
richtiges Hype
und
angesagtes Video erwischt.
Eggdrop from Space.
Aber...
Warum?
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Overwatch 2 ist erbärmlich.
Okay, jetzt geht's los.
Super Base in 100 Sekunden.
Pokémon, Karmazin und Puppe sind eine technische Katastrophe.
Ach komm, wir gucken das jetzt an.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was das Egg macht, wenn es vom Space droppt.
Schauen wir mal, wo davon...
Okay, hier scheint wieder alles zu funktionieren.
Excellent.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
Das Egg droppt vom Space.
Habt ihr in der Schule eine Egg-Drop-Kompetition gemacht?
Also, das ist mir neu.
Sowas haben wir nicht versucht.
Das ist ein Ami-Ding.
Ah ja.
Also, weißt du, wisst ihr, was ich mir so spontan einfallen würde,
was, glaube ich, wirklich ganz gut funktionieren müsste?
Einen großen Ball nehmen.
So einen Ball, wie man zum Beispiel im Schwimmbad nimmt.
Wie heißt dieser hier?
Ball.
Dieser aufblasbaren, zum Aufblasen.
Mein Chat-Overlay ist fünf Minuten zurück.
Fünf Minuten zurück?
Wirklich?
Nö.
Kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Das steht da drinnen.
Nö.
Das ist...
Du musst refreshen.
Das ist aktuell.
Also, bei mir.
Ja, so einen Ball.
Guckt mal.
So einen Ball müsste man nehmen.
So, sowas hier.
So einen aufblasbaren Ball.
Also, das ist das Erste, was mir so spontan einfällt, ja.
So einen aufblasbaren Ball und da das Ei irgendwie in die Mitte hängen.
Also, er müsste dann da innen drinnen, er müsste das halt irgendwie aufmachen und das Ei irgendwie an ein paar Gummis in die Mitte hängen.
Das ist das, das ist das Erste, was mir spontan einfallen würde, so einen Sinn.
Da kann man das wahrscheinlich von relativ hoch droppen, ohne dass was passiert.
Wenn man das Ganze jetzt noch mit Helium füllt oder so, dann fällt es noch langsamer.
Okay, auf geht's.
Okay.
Was passt dein T-Shirt für an?
Der würde platzen im Weltall.
Du musst, darfst ihn halt nicht so sehr aufpumpen.
Okay.
Und dann, wenn es 300 Meter über dem Boden liegt, würde es das Ei rauslassen, das auf eine Matratze, die wir auf dem Boden gelegt haben, frei fallen würde.
Und das alles sah ziemlich einfach aus.
Also, wie alle guten Ingenieure, haben wir das Problem in kleinere Schritte geschlossen,
erstens mit der Kalkulation der Turbinen.
Sag mal, das könnte ich mir vorstellen, das könnte schon funktionieren.
Im Vakuum wäre das deutlich einfacher,
und im Vakuum wäre das deutlich besser,
weil da fällt alles gleich schnell.
Alter, dass das das Ei aushält, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Guck mal hier, mit was für einem Ding, mit was für einer Power, die das dagegen donnert.
Ein guter Start.
Der nächste Schritt in unserem DIY-Space-Programm war,
zurück zu meinen Freunden in der kleinen Farming-Town von Gridley, Kalifornien,
das ist der Ort, wo wir den Elefant-Tuch-Base-Weltrekord gebrochen haben,
wo der Plan war, eine Target-Matratze für das Ei in der Mitte eines Feldes zu bauen,
mit ein bisschen Margin, die wir in der Lage haben.
Okay, also wir haben den Schmuck-Charge hier hinten,
sodass wir, als wir von dem Himmel herkommen,
können wir es auswählen.
Das ist der Computer, hier sind die Finen.
Das ist Joe, und er hat einen faszinierenden Kanal namens BPS-Space.
Und was ihn besonders cool macht,
ist, dass er nicht zur Schule gegangen ist, um irgendeinen Ingenieur-Degreit zu machen.
Er hat alles selbst gelehrt,
und hat vor kurzem sogar einen Launch-Rocket-Space-
Moment, Moment, Moment, mit dem Source-Code muss ich mich kurz angucken.
Was haben wir hier?
... ist Joe, und er hat einen faszinierenden Kanal namens BPS-Space.
Und was ihn besonders cool macht,
ist, dass er nicht zur Schule gegangen ist, um irgendeinen Ingenieur-Degreit zu machen.
Was bin ich da...
Ja, man erkennt nicht so genau, was das ist.
Irgendwelche Variablen-Zuweisung.
Das kann letztendlich alles sein.
Ich vermute aber mal,
dass die Rakete,
die bestimmt blazingly fast written in Rust ist.
Okay, da habe ich mir noch gar keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Stimmt, das Ei gefriert ja,
wenn man das zu hoch, hoch, ähm, schweben lässt.
Ist halt kalt.
All the time and money taking the balloon all the way up to space,
we're here just to do a low-altitude test at 10,000 feet,
just to prove to ourselves that we can steer the rocket using the fence.
We're setting all sorts of world records out here.
World's largest mattress, fastest egg, tallest egg drop.
What could possibly go wrong?
Besides, like, four thousand...
And so with everything more or less in place and ready to go,
all we needed now was an official egg,
which thankfully, Criddly has in abundance.
Hi, I'm sorry.
This is terrifying.
Ähm, war ne blöde Frage.
Warum nimmt er nicht einfach die Eier,
anstatt das Huhn zu verjagen?
Okay, okay.
Precious egg.
In the history of our universe,
this is the first chicken...
It is an animal egg.
That will go faster than the speed of sound.
Super Sonic Mach 1.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall ein...
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie's bei den Amis ist.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall irgendwas...
irgendeinen Luftraum, wo keine Flugzeuge sind,
und du musst das wahrscheinlich anmelden,
oder zum Hundertpro, hundertpro.
Musst du das irgendwie anmelden.
Oder eben auf Gebieten machen, wo es erlaubt ist.
Keine Ahnung, garantiert.
...was past, dass er über zahlreiche deep sound.
Super Sonic Mach 1.
So the next morning we got up at 4 a.m. when the winds would be the most calm to run through
all our final pre-launch preparations, including the last minute decision to add a metallic
streamer to the back of the rocket to make it easier to visually track.
We've got redundancy all over the place here, we've got redundant leads, redundant
igniters, Mark has two servos on the fairing, no dumb failures.
And that's exactly when we had our first dumb failure.
Ups.
Warum konnten sie nicht einfach ein neues?
Achso, weil die Befestigung nicht fest genug war.
And since the GPS unit was right at the back of the rocket, the last minute addition of
the metallic streamer was interfering with the GPS signal.
And that messed up the rocket's math in calculating its speed, so it thought it was time to release
the egg.
So early the next morning we were back at...
Ah, okay, ich dachte, das wäre einfach nicht fest genug gewesen.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Okay.
...with a few modifications, the most important being swapping the metallic tracking streamer
with one made from plastic.
Good news is there's hardly any wind today.
Bad news is about 20 degrees.
It's colder, which means our mattresses are kind of frozen.
Nevertheless, we pushed forward.
Don't trip, Mark.
As I very carefully delivered the rocket to the new balloon launch site.
Send it.
Send it, baby, we'll send it.
It's happening.
Okay, nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Die haben das Zeug an den Ballon gehängt.
Der fliegt hoch.
Dann releasen sie das.
Und sie haben eine Rakete dranhängen, die quasi das Ei dann per GPS zurücksteuern soll,
dass es über ihren Matratzen runterkommt.
Und kurz bevor es auf die Matratze haut, klinken sie das Ei irgendwie aus.
Und okay, okay, verstanden.
Also da habe ich meine Zweifel, dass das First Try funktioniert.
Es wird auch nicht First Try funktionieren, weil das Video geht ja noch 20 Minuten.
Warum rasten die immer so aus, alle?
Also wir...
...might be in trouble.
We quickly realized the balloon was rising at a slower rate than we anticipated.
We're already south and we're only halfway up.
Which totally threw off the predicted trajectory.
And so after a few more minutes, we decided to manually drop the rocket.
Because we were already way too far off course for the rocket to make up the lateral distance to the mattress.
Using just the fins and gravity.
3, 2, 1, clicked.
Oh boy.
Mon castillo.
And that's when we encountered the second problem of the day.
As the fins actively forced the rocket.
The rocket into an uncontrolled death spiral.
Altitude is 1,400, coming down...
Er will ja in den Weltraum.
Kommt man da nur mit einem Ballon hin?
Es ist wahrscheinlich die Frage, was man als Weltraum definiert.
Also sprich, dort wo gar keine Atmosphäre mehr ist, da kommst du nicht hin mit einem Ballon.
Es gibt ja aber so verschiedene Definitionen, ab wann, wie, wo, welche Stufe Weltraum ist.
Und vielleicht kommt man da mit einem Ballon noch hin.
Oh, das sieht nicht gut aus.
Well, it landed somewhere.
Check the mattress.
Just in case.
And since we have the GPS cord into the rocket, we headed out to track it down.
The real question is, what's the status of the egg?
Mark, I think I might have some bad news for you.
At which point we stumbled on an entire field of sitting birds.
Which is another opportunity I'm not gonna let just pass on by.
There's no egg.
The egg did release.
The fact that this is out means the egg did come out, so that's good.
But despite that silver lining, the movable fins...
Ist man auch davon wieder am abkacken?
Nö.
Da kackt nix ab.
Alles gut.
Da trockt nix.
Ich will mal...
Ah!
Okay, jetzt erkennt man wenigstens, was es ist.
Okay.
Es ist C.
Avasoft.
Was ist Avasoft?
Ah, guck mal, es ist ein Platform-IO-Projekt.
Erkennen wir da vielleicht noch irgendwie sonst was?
Erkennen wir da sonst noch irgendwas?
Ava ist der Name seines Flight-Computers.
Aha, aha.
Also auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Platform-IO-Projekt.
Das ist schon mal eine gute Sache.
Das macht es einfacher.
Ansonsten erkennt man nicht, was es für eine...
Ah, hier unten vielleicht was.
Teensy ist das.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das überhaupt noch...
... noch irgendjemand verwendet.
Das ist kein ESP2 in 3D und kein Arduino.
Das ist irgend so ein anderes Ding.
Teensy?
Ich hab gesagt, wurscht gar nicht, dass es das noch gibt.
Alles klar, wir wissen doch zumindest ein bisschen besser drüber Bescheid.
... causing all the control issues.
Which meant, we were ready to give this one final try.
We had run out of spare parts and spare weather balloons,
so regardless of outcome, this would be the final attempt.
If we couldn't land the egg on a mattress from 10,000 feet up,
we wouldn't have any hope of pulling it off,
coming all the way down from space.
Phenomenal!
That's nerdy space talk for everything is exactly...
Ich würde es sehr begrüßen, wenn die Leute nicht alle immer so rumschreien würden.
Ansonsten ist das Video ja interessant, aber das Rumgeschreien...
... unexpected.
I'm standing in the middle of the world's largest mattress,
where hopefully the egg will be landing in like 45 minutes.
Otherwise we're pivoting, and my new video is world's largest mattress.
So I'm arming the rocket right now.
The last step.
Alright, old girl, you're in for a ride.
3, 2, 1, let it ride, baby!
Woo-ha!
Looking good so far, we're at 500 meters.
Now in order for the balloon to hit the target mattress,
for each launch we'd start it from different spots around Gridley.
Which raises an interesting question maybe you've wondered yourself.
How do big balloons like hot air balloons steer themselves?
Or I guess, even just know where they're going to land?
And the answer is,
computers know the way to land.
Winddirection and speed at every height as you go up.
So on a given day, if these are the predicted winddirections and speeds,
we would need to launch here to be directly above the mattress when we got to 10,000 feet.
But how we know all this information is the fascinating part.
Because every day it's someone's job to launch two balloons like this into the sky at noon and midnight London time.
But this is done in over a thousand local...
Und was machen die damit?
Werden dann irgendwelche Wetterdaten gesammelt damit, oder?
Und was ist der Sinn davon?
...at those same two exact moments.
And these balloons all have something called a radiosonde attached to them,
that measures things like altitude, pressure, temperature and wind,
and then they transmit the information back to the ground station,
which gets fed into...
Ist das, dass man bessere Wettervorhersage bekommt, oder?
...supercomputers, and that's the reason weather and wind predictions can be so accurate.
So 2,000 of these massive weather balloons go up every day,
and then eventually pop and just land somewhere.
And since they're transmitting a signal,
some folks make a hobby out of just trying to track them down.
How close are we to the drop point?
Okay.
Das finde ich...
Das ist ja besser als Geocaching oder sowas.
Wetterballon-Caching.
Ist da irgendwelche Technik drin, die interessant ist, warum man die einsammeln sollte?
Balloon release?
Balloon release.
That's it.
And this time we were releasing right in the target drop zone,
which was good news on one hand,
but it raised some new challenges on the other.
Where is it?
Grab a chair!
You see something?
Altitude 98 meters...
Ah!
Das sieht nicht nach Matratze aus.
Everyone okay?
Alter, schrei doch net so, Mann.
So we were much closer this time and we even managed to steer the rocket in the right direction just slightly.
We found it.
Good.
Okay, also es hat anscheinend nicht wirklich funktioniert, das zu den Matratzen zu steuern.
Er ist auch der Chef-Ingenieur für Perseveranz und Mars-Sammel-Return.
Und so, nachdem Adam erklärt hat, was wir versuchen,
hat er sofort einen fädelischen Fehler in unserem brillanten Plan.
Und du machst Terminal-Guidanz zu etwas, das die Größe eines Hauses ist.
Wie machst du das? Wie machst du das?
Ich meine, ich weiß, wie du das physisch machst.
Wie kannst du nicht von der FAA verletzt werden?
In anderen Worten, wir haben im Grunde genommen versucht,
ein präzisioniertes Missil zu machen.
Dude, es gibt Tausende von Leuten, die das schon gemacht haben,
und sie sind von der FED-Law gezwungen,
nicht zu zwingen.
Und um ehrlich zu sein, hat er einen guten Punkt erwähnt.
Die Leute, die uns helfen können, können es nicht.
Und auch wenn wir es uns selbst herausgefunden haben,
sind die Ethiken, das Video auf YouTube zu machen,
am besten fragwürdig.
Und so, nach einer fruchtbaren Diskussion mit Adam,
Wir haben uns entschieden,
und anstatt eines präzisionierten Messers in einer kleinen Stadt zu landen,
würden wir unsere Szenen auf einem sehr,
viel generelleren Messerspiegel-Target auswählen,
wenn wir in die Wälder gehen.
Aber als Teil des Pivots haben wir unser altes Design komplett verpasst
und haben ein paar Monate lang das Design und das Bauen eines neuen Systems
gebraucht, das stark von der Curiosity-Landung abhängt.
Weil wir feststellten, dass es, wenn es ein Rover auf Mars aufbaut,
ein Messer auf der Erde aufbaut.
Also würden wir immer noch in den Raum auf einem Wetterballon landen,
aber dieses Mal würde der Messer Fins haben, die nicht bewegen,
und es wäre drei Mal so lang und vier Mal so schwer,
um sicherzustellen, dass wir das Messer auf supersonicen Geschwindigkeiten
auf dem Weg nach unten bringen würden.
Dann, wie NASA die Kruise-Stage in der Oberfläche separiert,
und dann Aero-Breaking verwendet, um das Messer aufbauen zu können.
Warum genau wollen sie, dass das Ei über Schallgeschwindigkeit schnell ist?
Einfach für mehr Weltrekord, oder?
... viel Energie und Geschwindigkeit.
Wir würden die Rückseite des Messers ungefähr halb so weit entfernen,
nachdem wir die Geräusch-Berührung bereits gebrochen hätten,
und weil das jetzt viel weniger ist,
würde es natürlich Aero-Breaking machen,
und seine Geschwindigkeit zu einer neuen, niedrigeren Terminal-Velocity reduzieren.
Dann auf Mars, der nächste Schritt ist,
die Parasiten-Kopplung zu folgen,
durch die Heimschütz-Separation,
und wir würden die Parasiten-Kopplung folgen,
indem wir unsere eigene Parasiten-Kopplung starten,
und dann unsere eigene Nase-Kopplung auslösen,
die dann unsere Kuschel-Aerobäge auslösen,
wie Sie hier sehen,
die wir vom Geist und von der Gelegenheit gebraucht haben.
Es war intensiv ambitioniert und extrem kompliziert,
aber nach ein paar Monaten kompletter Redesign und Bau
haben wir uns in der Wälder gefunden,
fühlend vorsichtig optimistisch.
Und das war in Teilen zu unserer glücklichen orange Parasiten-Kopplung,
weil, als ich von NASA gelaufen bin,
haben meine Freunde mir dieses rektanguläre Stück Nylons gegeben.
Und für die Größe, das ist genau das gleiche Rektangul hier,
das Teil der Parasiten,
die der Curiosity-Rover landete.
Also das Stück Parasiten ist tatsächlich einer der 80 Rektangeln,
die Sie hier sehen,
als sie die letzten Tests im weltweit größten Windtunnel runnten.
Und so fühlte es sich nur gut an,
dass nach einigen Zeichnungen,
ein bisschen Kutzen und ein bisschen Sägen
es sich für die neue Mission wiederholt hat.
für die neue Mission wiederholt hat.
So als die Sonne runterging,
arbeiteten wir im Hotel abends
auf die letzten Präparationen.
Das war eine Idee und ein Leidenschaftsprojekt,
drei Jahre lang.
So als die Sonne runterging,
arbeiteten wir im Hotel abends
auf die letzten Präparationen.
So als die Sonne runterging,
arbeiteten wir im Hotel abends
auf die letzten Präparationen.
Das war eine Idee und ein Leidenschaftsprojekt,
drei Jahre lang.
So als die Sonne runterging,
arbeiteten wir im Hotel abends
auf die letzten Präparationen.
Wir haben uns gedacht und vorbereitet
für so viele Dinge,
die wir falsch machen können.
Wir haben uns gedacht und vorbereitet
für so viele Dinge,
die wir falsch machen können.
Aber wie wie hadi ein Ei
an einem Wetterballon
hochsteigen lassen und dann wieder
runterfallen lassen...
Da kann man glaube ich vielleicht
im Ansatz zu schätzen 2002
Sachen, Leute ins Weltraum bringen,
Leute die sie auf der Erde wieder
zurückbringen können,
Leute auf den Mond bringen,
Leute die sicher wieder zurückbringen können.
was wir hier hinbekommen haben. Deswegen finde ich es auch immer so cringe, wenn dann irgendwelche Leute anfangen, von wegen, ja, die internationale Raumstation wäre unter Wasser, die Mondlandung ist fake und generell, generell ist das alles CGI und die Erde ist natürlich auch flach.
Flach. Ja, oder auf einem Asteroid landen oder einen Teleskop so positionieren, dass es eben quasi gravitationstechnisch recht neutral ist und am Arsch der Welt trifft ja noch nicht mal so quasi, fast schon am Arsch des Sonnensystems hinzufliegen.
Also da ist schon, da steckt schon so viel dahinter.
Und dass man das dann so komplett, ähm, tja, so redet, als wäre das überhaupt nicht existent, ja, das stört mich teilweise schon. Gerade diese ganze Flat Earth Geschichte auf YouTube ist so ein Ding, wo ich echt nicht verstehen kann, dass das die letzten Jahre über so ein großes Teil geworden ist.
Ich mein, wisst ihr, es gab ja schon immer Leute, die was von hohler Erde erzählt haben und sonstige Geschichten. Jetzt ist es halt aktuell flache Erde.
Aber ich dachte eigentlich nie...
Dass die Leute das wirklich, wirklich, wie soll ich sagen, wirklich überzeugt davon sind, sondern dass das eher so rumgetrolle ist.
Aber wenn man sich da auf YouTube umguckt, es gibt tatsächlich genug, die scheinen davon unglaublich überzeugt zu sein.
Und es gibt noch ein paar andere, die schlagen da Kapital draus, dass es ein paar Überzeugte gibt und produzieren dann Content dafür.
Und das ist ein bisschen anders als die anderen.
Weil es ein Null-Pressure-Wetterballon ist.
Der Vorteil, den diese haben über einen typischen Wetterballon, ist, dass sie höher in den Raum gehen können, mehr Gewicht tragen und sie auf der Nase offen sind, was bedeutet, dass sie sich mit der Druck gleich machen und es unmöglich ist, dass sie poppen.
Also wenn du es runter wollen willst, sendest du ein Signal, das auf einen String herunter geht, das auf den Seite des Ballons ist und es öffnet sich wie ein Zipper und sich selbst zerstört.
Der Vorteil ist, dass sie unglaublich leicht und so dünn und lecker sind, dass du wirklich vorsichtig musst.
Das sieht aus wie eine Plastiktüte vom Aldi.
... mit Knochen.
Und sie waren etwa eine Stunde lang.
Warum?
... mit Knochen.
Was muss ich mir angucken? Die Känguru-Verschwörung?
Also, das kenne ich nicht.
Ich kenne ein paar Videos auf YouTube von einem Typ, der sagt, dass Pinguine nicht existieren.
Weiß nicht, ob das jemand von euch gesehen hat, das ist auch sehr lustig.
Also quasi auch Pinguine in Zoos und so, das ist alles Fake.
Das ist richtig keck Alu-Time.
Pinguine existieren nicht.
Linux-Hater, genau.
Are you serious?
Ich bin ja auch nicht bei Twitch.
Der Wobblos ist ja bei Twitch.
Da sind sie in guter Gesellschaft.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, als vor ein paar Jahren bei der Internationalen Raumstation irgendwelche Schläuche,
nicht aneinandergepasst haben, weil die einen in Inches und die anderen in Zentimeter gerechnet haben.
Nur nochmal erwähnt, ja.
Wie kam es dazu?
Ich habe den Channel hier angelegt und den Namen einfach für einen Twitch-Channel, wo ich gucke.
Ich wollte da gar nicht selbst streamen.
Und irgendwann habe ich gerade nicht gestreamt, selbst habe ich den Channel behalten.
Habe den Namen halt behalten.
Ist gar nicht so schlecht, weil dann kommen bloß HIQ-Leute von YouTube rüber.
Ich habe eine Frage an euch, jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Okay, ich muss das in zwei Fragen splitten.
Wer von euch ist nur von Twitch da und kannte YouTube früher nicht?
Also kennt vielleicht jetzt meinen YouTube, aber wer hat mich auf Twitch gefunden und nicht auf YouTube?
Und nicht über YouTube?
Es sind nicht so viele, ja, aber ich weiß, dass es ein paar gibt.
Okay.
So, und jetzt die nächste Frage.
Würde es euch verwirren, wenn ich hier MaxFPS anstatt Wubblors heißen würde?
Würde euch nicht verwirren?
Umfrage, ja.
Können wir machen.
Fändet ihr es besser, und nächste Frage.
Fändet ihr es besser, wenn ich MaxFPS heißen würde anstelle von Wubblors auf Twitch?
Okay, ich mache eine Umfrage.
Zusätzliche Abstimmung erlauben will ich nicht, dauert eine Minute.
Okay, Umfrage.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was rauskommt.
Wie kann der verwirrt sein? Das ist eigentlich nicht möglich, hast du schon recht, ja.
Der ist schon vergeben, der ist nicht vergeben.
Der gehört mir.
Der...
Ich habe mir das reserviert vor zehn Jahren oder so.
Okay, das ist wirklich ziemlich 50-50, man.
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das so 50-50 ausgeht.
Okay, es geht genau 50-50 aus, man.
Ja, das eine ist genau 50-50.
Dann doch WubFPS.
Das hätte ich echt nicht gedacht.
Okay.
Ja, bin ich jetzt genauso schlau wie vorher?
Wäre Wubblors für YouTube?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Rundungsfehler, würde ich sagen.
Das war mir ja klar.
Tja, dann bin ich genauso schlau wie vorher.
So, wir gucken das Video jetzt fertig.
Muss ich nur mal kurz...
Wubblors heißt eigentlich gar nichts Großartiges.
Ich musste irgendwas eingeben, als ich einen Twitch-Account erstellt habe.
Wie viele M-Bits hast du?
Hier, 100 Down, 40 Up.
Fantastic.
Alter, was machen die da?
Gachi Bass.
Es gibt keine anderen Ballons, wirklich?
Also, ja, ich glaube ihm das.
Aber für mich sieht das aus wie ein übergroßer gelber Sack.
Oder wie so eine übergroße Aldi-Tüte.
Wahrscheinlich ist es deutlich komplizierter als einfach eine Aldi-Tüte.
Es ist halt eine große, große Aldi-Tüte.
Und das war ein absoluter Low-Point für mich.
Die Integration von zwei individuellen Systemen ist so ein klassischer Fehlerpunkt in der Technik.
Ich war überrascht, dass ich das verpasst habe.
Überrascht?
Ich fühlte mich, als hätte ich einfach alle abgelassen.
Nicht nur mein Team und die anderen, die da waren.
Nee, ich hab nicht automatisch mehr Upload bekommen.
Das musste man umstellen.
Aber alle anderen Leute,
einige von denen haben 6 Stunden gedauert, um auch raus zu kommen und zu schauen.
Aber das ist das Problem mit Fehler.
Sie können wie verrückt stinken,
aber es ist wirklich nur ein Prozess,
um einen weiteren Weg zu lernen, nicht etwas zu machen.
Und so, selbst als ich da saß,
mich ziemlich schlecht fühlte,
wie jeder gute Ingenieur,
hatte ich bereits eine Liste mit all den Dingen, die wir fixieren werden.
Wechsel, danke schön für den Sub.
Ach nee, ich hab mich verguckt.
Der hat nur gefolgt.
Trotzdem, danke für den Follower.
Verguckt.
... um hier wieder raus zu kommen und diese verdammte Sache noch einmal zu probieren.
Und das Prinzip ist,
dass Resilienz etwas ist, was ich glaube,
lernt werden kann.
In Wahrheit glaube ich das so sehr,
dass ich eine Toilettenfirma mit dem Ziel gestartet habe,
Kinder als Ingenieure zu helfen zu denken.
Also mit dem Build Box nicht nur...
Ach, das ist Werbung jetzt.
... 3. Wir bauten für die 2 Stunden
und separierten die beiden Halter
mit einem Black Powder Charge.
2. Wir haben ein paar Vakuum- und Temperatur-Tests gemacht
auf einem rohen Ei.
Es gibt keine Luftdämpfer und es ist wirklich, wirklich kalt im Raum.
Also, wenn du nicht etwas tust, um das Ei zu schützen,
für die 2 Stunden, die es dauert, um das Ballon hochzukommen,
wird es immer wieder kratzen und kratzen.
Also haben wir ein paar Heater getestet
in unserem Eierzimmer
und haben bemerkt, dass sie das Ei warm genug halten.
3. Wir haben Redundanz in unserem System gebaut.
Wenn NASA etwas an Mars schickt,
können sie es nicht da hin, um es zu schützen.
Also muss es einfach funktionieren.
Und deshalb haben viele kritische Systeme Backups.
Selbst die Teil von meiner eigenen Hardware
von Curiosity, die ein Dirt-Sammel
vom Arm in den Bellen des Rovers akzeptiert hat,
hatte 2 Türen, die auf dem selben Ort
geöffnet wurden, in dem Falle,
dass eine der Türen nicht mehr funktioniert.
In diesem Falle bedeutet Redundanz,
einen 2-Foot-Wide-Kustom-Beach-Ball zu machen,
Hey! Ein Beach-Ball!
mit einem zweiten Ei,
mit 20-Foot-Streamer,
Das ist aber nicht so ein Ball, wie ich meinte.
Ich meinte so ein Plastik-Ding zum Aufblasen.
Aber ich find's lustig,
dass ihr auf eine ähnliche Idee kommt.
Es wäre sehr einfach.
Keine Parachutes,
keine autonomen Timing-Sequenzen
und keine lustigen Mechanismen.
Das wäre unser Redundanz,
aber ich würde auch sagen, etwas nervig,
um einen Safe-Egg zu landen.
Er hat an dem Rover mitgearbeitet?
Nee, der Typ, den er da befragt hat,
zu der Rakete, hat
an einem Rover mitgearbeitet.
We went to a local crane yard
to test both our solutions
at their respective terminal velocities,
starting first with the Beach-Ball.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
dass sie nicht kaputt gegangen ist.
And after that,
we tested the final landing configuration
of the rocket.
Oh yeah!
By the way, the actual rover parachute
held perfectly.
And so after all that,
we made the six-hour trek back to the desert
for what I was really, really hoping
would be the last time.
After four failed attempts,
we had learned so much,
which left me feeling cautiously optimistic.
And right out of the gate,
we got two bits of really good news.
The first relates to that super-delicate
Zero-Pressure-Balloon we had to reuse
because there was no possible way
to get a replacement.
Just barely touching the balloon
leaves it stressed and creates a weak point
for it to tear, so I was obsessively
checking the fish-scale reading
that would give us the verdict.
The force reading is 37.6 kilograms
of buoyancy force pulling this up.
Importantly, it's not changing.
If it were changing and going down,
that means we would have a leak.
But it's holding steady at 37.6.
That's a big deal.
A piece of good news is my buddy
and warm-blooded good luck charm,
Al Chen, had arrived.
You might recognize Al as the other guy
here with Adam, and he's the one
who actually said this.
Touchdown confirmed. We're safe on Mars.
If we were successful,
he'd be the one to make the official call.
And so, after all the work
and last-minute preparations
in three long years,
it was finally time for liftoff.
Three, two, one.
And everything was looking good.
The balloon ascent rate was just
what we predicted, and that meant
we for sure didn't have a leak,
and things were finally breaking our way.
Is that how it's supposed to look?
And it takes about two hours
to get all the way up to space.
So once the balloon hit 30,000 feet,
we decided to hop in the car
so we could drive over
to the predicted landing spot
about 45 minutes away.
So far, it's all systems nominal.
Balloons in the air, it's ascending
at the right rate.
We have some critical threshold points.
And we're still in the game.
Fifth time is the charm, as they say.
We eventually started outrunning
the balloon in the car,
so we pulled over for a bit
as we reached an important altitude milestone
of 100,000 feet.
I would say over 100.
Woo!
Over 100.
That's 19 miles up
and two and a half miles to go.
And we're still in the game.
That's 19 miles up
and two and a half times higher
than a typical commercial plane flies.
And because the balloon expands
so large as it rises,
we realized we could actually
even spot it from the ground,
which was awesome.
Dude, that's totally it.
What wasn't awesome
was when moments later Joe,
while looking through the binoculars,
made this gut-wrenching observation.
It looked really big
and it seemed to be smaller.
But it's just weird
that it would just completely disappear.
Which was followed by a devastating call
from the balloon tracking team.
It dropped within the last two minutes.
Yeah.
That's 30,000 feet over the last however.
But these don't pop.
There's zero pressure.
And that's true. They don't pop.
But unbeknownst to us,
while we were looking at it from the ground,
the rocket and beach ball had been spinning
around and around relative to the balloon
This meant the cord that attaches to the string
that self-destructs the balloon
was getting wrapped around tighter and tighter
until it was so tight
it pulled down on the balloon string
that is designed to essentially unzip
and destroy itself.
And so before we even had the chance to release
the rocket and beach ball from the balloon,
it all started coming down in one big tangled heap
at 150 miles per hour,
which is way faster than the eggs could survive.
Well, let's start driving.
And as we drove over, all I could think about
was how our fate would rest solely in the hands
of the redundant systems we'd put in place.
We think it's
probably about
two miles up that way.
This was our Apollo 13 moment.
If our payload could autonomously
jettison itself from the tangled rocket balloon
mess at 20,000 feet, then it would be
able to deploy our lucky orange parachute
and land the egg safely
on its airbags. And as we parked,
we knew what was done was done.
There was nothing left to do but go on a hunt
to find the wreckage
and reveal our fate.
I see something orange.
That looks like a rover parachute.
Okay.
We've got a thing.
Alter, schreit doch nicht so rum, man.
All by itself was a huge deal.
Because it meant it had actually autonomously
ejected itself from the mangled weather balloon
mess at 20,000 feet.
And later when we checked the footage,
this is exactly what it confirmed.
And while that was incredible news,
I knew by this point not to get my hopes up.
So let's look through the window.
A little bit of dirt.
Touchdown confirmed.
Whether or not we're safe on our TVD, right?
Let's check it out to be sure.
Oh, man.
Waren es 20,000 feet
oder 200,000 feet?
Weil 20,000 feet wären ein bisschen
niedrig. Das wäre irgendwie so
Mount Everest Höhe oder sowas.
100,000 feet.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
100,000 feet sind...
Was sind 100,000 feet?
30.000 Meter oder so, ne?
Touchdown confirmed.
We're safe on Earth.
30 Kilometer.
Das Ei ist wieder da.
It was in space
and now it's on Earth
and it's not broken.
After that we tracked down the beach ball,
which as far as I was concerned
was just extra credit at this point.
This is the backup, the simple solution,
the true engineer's solution here.
Oh, my gosh.
Look at that. We're safe on Earth.
Two for two, baby.
Two for two.
As we walked away with two uncracked eggs in hand,
I was reminded that in life
things rarely unfold how we think they will.
But by learning from your failures,
coupled with a bit of tenacity,
us humans can accomplish a feat as incredible...
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Einfach das Ding
demnächst in den Ball packen
und aus dem Flugzeug schmeißen. Easy.
Jetzt erst mal Rührei.
Genau.
Aha. Na gut.
GG Eats.
Was hat man sonst noch hier?
Overwatch 2 ist erbärmlich.
Oh, nee. Das müssen wir jetzt nicht.
Super Base in 100 Seconds.
Okay, komm, Leute. Wir gucken uns eine Runde Fireship an.
Fireship hat immer Pog-Videos.
Danach gucken wir uns den
Hochzeitsredner an.
Wie lange geht denn das? Elf Minuten.
Alles klar.
Super Base.
A complete backend for web and mobile applications
based entirely on
free open source software.
Ist das written in Rust blazingly fast?
...when building an app
is not writing code,
but rather architecting a complete system
that works at scale.
Products like Firebase and Amplify
have addressed this barrier,
but there's one big problem.
They lock you into proprietary technology
on a specific cloud platform.
Super Base was created in 2019
specifically as an open source
Firebase alternative.
At a high level it provides two things.
On the backend we have infrastructure
like a database, file storage
and edge functions that run in the cloud.
On the frontend we have client-site SDKs
that can easily connect this infrastructure
to your favorite frontend JavaScript framework,
React Native, Flutter and
Warum genau braucht man das?
Ich mein, irgendeine Backend-Anwendung
mit einem GraphQL
mit irgendeinem GraphQL-Endpunkt
ist jetzt ja auch kein Hexenwerk zu erstellen.
...many other platforms.
As a developer you could manage your Postgres database
with an easy-to-understand UI,
which automatically generates REST
and GraphQL APIs to use in your code.
The database integrates directly
with user authentication.
Okay, Authentifizierung ist vielleicht ganz nice,
aber ich meine halt so eine Backend-Anwendung
die ein GraphQL-Endpunkt zur Verfügung stellt
ist fünf Zeilen Code.
...almost trivial to implement
row-level security.
And like Firebase, it can listen to data changes
in real time while scaling to virtually any workload.
To get started, you can self-host
Docker or sign up for a fully managed account
that starts with a free tier.
On the dashboard, you can create tables
in your Postgres database with the click of a button.
Insert columns to build out your schema,
then add new rows to populate it with data.
Das ist doch so ein Ding,
das ist für Frontend-Entwickler da, oder?
Die sich mit Backend-Sachen
überhaupt nicht beschäftigen wollen.
...project has an authentication schema
to manage users within the application.
This opens the door to row-level security
where you write policies
to control who has access to your data.
In addition, the database supports triggers
to react to changes in your data
and Postgres functions
to run stored procedures directly on the database server.
It's a nice interface,
but it also automatically generates
custom API documentation for you.
From here we can copy queries
tailored to our database
and use them in a JavaScript project.
Install the Supabase SDK with npm
and connect to your project...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Lull, ich hab mich schon gewundert.
Heißt das, man macht dann quasi
so eine SQL-Style-Abfrage
im Frontend?
Ja, gut, warum nicht?
Aber ich meine, dafür gibt es ja
zum Beispiel Sachen wie CraftQL.
Da kannst du sowas auch abfragen.
Und ob das jetzt so viel besser ist,
weiß ich nicht.
...in a JavaScript project,
install the Supabase SDK with npm,
then connect to your project
and sign a user in with a single line of code.
And now we can listen to any changes
in the application state in real time
with on-auth state change.
When it comes to the database,
we don't need to write raw SQL code.
Instead, we can paste in that JavaScript code
from the API docs
or use the REST and GraphQL APIs directly.
And that's all it takes to build
an authenticated full-stack application.
However, you may still want to run
your own custom server-side code,
in which case serverless edge functions
can be developed with Deno and TypeScript
then easily distributed around the globe.
This has been Supabase in 100 seconds.
I don't know why I should use it,
I don't get it.
...on this platform,
we just released a brand new Supabase course
on Fireship IO.
It's free to get started,
so check it out to learn more.
Thanks for watching,
and I will see you in the next one.
Also was ist jetzt genau der Vorteil davon
gegenüber irgendwie ner kleinen,
was weiß ich, go.net-Sonstwas-Anwendung
mit nem GraphQL-Endpunkt?
Okay, die muss ich nicht selbst machen.
Weil da kann ich nicht anpassen,
wie ich's haben will.
Jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde,
oh ja, ich wüsste sofort, wofür ich das brauchen könnte.
Die ist nicht super,
das stimmt.
Nur Supabase ist super.
Black Friday, kann man wirklich was sparen?
Ehrlich gesagt,
das meiste ist einfach Blödsinn.
Du kannst sparen,
manchmal bei solchen Sachen wie,
wenn Amazon Firetablets und sowas raushaut,
aber im Großen und Ganzen wird man nicht so viel sparen.
Zumal die Angebote oftmals
richtiger Cheap Bates sind.
So nach dem Motto, heute kostet die SSD
170 Euro.
Sonst kostet sie
Nur dass dann beim Black Friday einfach
der sonstige Preis hochgeschraubt wird,
dass man hinschreiben konnte,
27% reduziert.
Man kann einfach sich sparen, sinnlosen Scheiß zu kaufen,
dann spart man auch Geld. Das ist korrekt.
Generell muss man sagen,
wenn man mehr Geld behält,
als Geld ausgibt, hat man immer Geld.
Also einfach nur,
sinnlose Sachen kaufen.
Ist notiert.
This Gaming PC can play any game.
Lass mich raten, das ist irgendeine Streaming-Geschichte, oder?
Ja, warum baue ich mir dann überhaupt
einen 4000 Euro PC?
Warum kaufe ich nicht einfach einen 200 Dollar PC?
Oh! Ups.
Ich habe gerade mein Tablett runtergeschmissen hier.
Vom Tisch. Ist aber nichts passiert,
weil da steht nichts mehr drauf.
Keck wait.
Muss ich auch mal kurz aufheben.
Du-du-du-du-du.
Ein paar Krümel.
Also wie gesagt, ich tendiere aktuell zur
Wasserkühlung im PC.
Kaviar auf dem PC.
Äh, auf dem Boden.
Was habe ich gerade gesagt über mehr Geld behalten als ausgeben?
Das wäre das Gegenteil.
So, was können wir uns denn noch angucken?
Overwatch ist erbärmlich.
Ja, wir wollen es jetzt mal nicht übertreiben.
Hochzeiten sind sein Job.
So arbeitet
ein selbstständiger
frei...
freier Trauergegner. Lohnt sich das?
Das würde ich für kein Geld
der Welt machen, alter Trauredner.
Okay, komm. Auf.
Gehen wir uns das jetzt.
Für kein Geld. Also Hochzeiten ist eh schon was,
wo ich fernbleibe.
Ähm.
Sofern es möglich ist. Aber freiwillig
dann auch noch ganz viel Abstand.
Gut. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man damit
schon ganz gut Geld verdienen kann, weil bei der
Hochzeit ist es ja so, da geben die Leute gerne mal
mehr Geld aus, als sinnvoll ist.
Ich bin 21, muss mich umziehen.
Der Traurige...
Hat man da normalerweise nicht
irgendwelche Bekannte, die das machen?
Oder ist das, wenn Leute ohne Freunde heiraten?
... ist eigentlich nur ein Teil
meines Einkommens.
Und jetzt dürft ihr euch küssen und alle anderen
dürfen sich freuen.
Das ist das beste Brautpaar, was ich
je hatte.
Das sagt er bestimmt
bei allen.
Das sagt er bestimmt bei allen.
Guck mal, das sieht...
Klingt auch schon so wahnsinnig
überzeugend, oder?
Das ist das beste Brautpaar, was ich je hatte.
Ist klar, ist klar.
Mein Opa hätte jetzt... Ne, das sage ich nicht.
Das ist ja schon heutzutage...
Wieder Cancelgrund, wenn ich das jetzt
gesagt hätte.
Hallihallo, ich bin der Hendrik. Ich bin Trauredner
und Sänger in Berlin und um Berlin. Moin Hendrik.
Und heute werde ich euch zeigen, wie
ein Tag eines Trauredners so aussieht.
Früher habe ich immer das ganze Hemd gebügelt,
bis ich irgendwann...
Jetzt wird optimiert. Jetzt wird nur noch das halbe Hemd gebügelt.
...begriffen habe, dass man sieht ja eigentlich nur den Ausschnitt.
Mehr sieht man ja nicht.
Optimized.
Bügelstrategie optimiert.
Das ist er.
Normalerweise
treffe ich mich mit den Leuten sechs Monate
vorher und schreibe dann auch relativ
zeitnah die Rede. Also so fünf Monate vorher ist
die Rede meistens, jedenfalls in Teilen,
ist sie dann fertig.
Ein junges Paar, relativ jung,
mit einem kleinen
Kind haben sich über
Online-Dating kennengelernt, wie
mittlerweile extrem viele meiner Paare.
Und da kann man aber auch immer
relativ viel rausholen.
Da kann man sehr mit spielen, mit diesem Online-Dating.
Bei mir wird das umgesetzt eben dadurch, dass
die Kennenlerngeschichte, die ja individuell
ist, einen großen Teil einnimmt.
Außerdem gibt es Zuarbeiten
von Familie und Freunden.
Die schönsten Dinge fasse ich zusammen.
Und das Brautpaar selbst bekommt auch noch Fragebögen.
Die die dann getrennt voneinander ausfüllen sollen.
Okay, das ist richtig optimiert.
Optimierter Wedding-Workflow.
Real Frité Orangé für den Zap.
Ich habe sehr viel persönliches Material
und brauche daher nicht mehr viel Austauschbares.
Wenn er das Ganze jetzt noch in Super-Bass
festhält, dann ist alles gut.
Aber ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass
während der Trauzeremonie wird es, glaube ich,
auch sehr romantisch.
Man sollte schon natürlich gepflegt aussehen.
Das wollen die Leute. In einem schicken Anzug
sein und so weiter.
Man sollte nicht in eine komplette Aversion gehen.
Da muss man auch noch ein paar
Anmoden haben.
Na gut, du solltest vielleicht als Trauredner
nicht als wieder letzter Penner hingehen.
Das kann ich mal verstehen.
Viermal drücken, dann ist der Akku voll.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Ach, der bringt seinen eigenen Lautsprecher mit?
Vier.
Es passiert immer wieder mal,
dass irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Ich bin immer gerüstet,
um Fußball zu spielen mit meinem Sohn.
Ganz häufig
...
Fahr ich dann direkt nach der Trauung
zu ihm und dann spielen wir ein bisschen Fußball.
Weil er hat mal am Wochenende
«nicht so viel von mir, ne?»
Das erste Mal
hab ich natürlich Technik dabei.
Ich hab Boxen dabei, Mikrofon,
Stativ. Außerdem ist
gerade im Umland
von Berlin so die
Abdeckung des öffentlichen Nachverkehrs.
Wenn ich hier zu einer bestimmten Zeit irgendwo sein muss...
Der Berlin ist ja eh Abfahrt.
Letzte Woche muss ich von Hanau
noch Würzburg fahren, mal gucken, ob die Bahn da mitspielt. Normalerweise dauert das so 1,15 oder so,
aber tja, mal gucken. Man muss natürlich bei der Planung die Schlechtwettervariante unbedingt auch
in Betracht ziehen. Es regnet durch und man sieht, man muss jetzt mit diesen 80 Leuten in dem viel zu
kleinen Innenraum die ganze Zeit sein und dann kann man nur sagen, Fehlplanung. Heute sieht's fantastisch aus.
Wir hatten ja gestern ein bisschen Regen, ich hoffe, das ist jetzt durch. Und Sonne-Wolken-Mix, aktuell 23 Grad,
also das ist perfektes Hochzeitswetter. Lisa und Tobias werden sich sehr freuen.
Und hoffentlich pünktlich überweist.
Technik funktioniert nicht immer. Die Herausforderung ist immer, dann möglichst gut zu improvisieren, das heißt, man sollte sehr gut vorbereitet sein,
man sollte also ein extra Kabel, falls da was kaputt ist,
geht. Und man sollte die Technik kennen.
Das Schicksal wollte mich in diese Richtung lenken, sozusagen. Ich war Animateur, da hab ich gelernt,
irgendwie Brücken zu Menschen zu schlagen, auch auf Menschen zuzugehen ganz stark. Ich war früher eher schüchtern, tatsächlich.
Dann hab ich moderiert auf Kreuzfahrtschiffen, dann hab ich eine Musical-Ausbildung gemacht, wo ich gelernt habe, dass ich nicht nur die Musik, sondern auch die Musik, die ich mag.
Dann hab ich eine Musical-Ausbildung gemacht, wo ich gelernt habe, dass ich nicht nur die Musik, sondern auch die Musik, die ich mag.
Dann hab ich eine Musical-Ausbildung gemacht, wo ich gelernt habe, dass ich nicht nur die Musik, die ich mag.
Guck mal, es ist eine ganz kurze Änderung in diesem Wort von Trauredner zu Trauerredner.
Also der könnte theoretisch fast schon auch auf Beerdigung sprechen.
Der Grund, warum ich aus dem Musical dann ausgestiegen bin, war ein gesundheitlicher Grund.
Ich hatte tendenziell, könnte man sagen, vor 20 Jahren Long-Covid.
Also ich hatte nach einer Virusinfektion...
Ich konnte vor 20 Jahren kein Long-Covid haben.
Influenza, Grippe, hat mein Körper gesagt, er will nicht mehr.
Und das ist etwas, das bis heute da ist.
Okay, er hatte was anderes.
Ich habe gelernt, damit umzugehen.
21, ich muss mich umziehen.
Das war gar keine chinesische Fledermaus, von der das kam.
Im Englischen gibt es zwei Bezeichnungen.
Wir sagen Nervös, das gibt es auch im Amerikanischen.
I'm nervous.
Aber dann gibt es...
I'm excited.
Es ist genau dasselbe körperlich, aber es ist eher etwas Positives.
Excited sind die immer bei irgendwelchen Spielekonferenzen und Präsentationen.
Da sind sie nicht nur excited, da sind sie thrilled und super excited und hyped und sonst was.
Ich freue mich drauf und deswegen bin ich...
Ich möchte gerne loslegen.
Bis gleich.
Der Trauredner ist eigentlich nur ein Teil meines Einkommens letztlich,
weil ich irgendwann mich entschieden habe, auch unternehmerisch tätig zu werden,
nämlich mit einem Internetportal.
Das dreht sich trotzdem noch.
Alles, was mit Traurednern zu tun hat.
Ich habe also ein Portal, bei dem...
Trauredner-Vermittler.
...Trauredner gelistet sind und eben Mitgliedsbeiträge zahlen...
Trauredner24.
...internet dann anzubieten auf diesem Portal.
Außerdem mache ich Ausbildungen für Trauredner.
Hallo liebe Trauredner und Traurednerinnen und herzlich willkommen bei einem weiteren Modul der Trauredner.
Und so kommt also mein Einkommen...
Ob es da auch eine Telegram-Gruppe für gibt?
...ein Einkommen setzt sich zusammen aus der Rede...
...aus der Rednertätigkeit, den Mitgliedsbeiträgen, die ich bekomme,
damit andere Rednerkollegen auf meinem Portal gelistet sind
und dann dem, was eben die angehenden Trauredner und Traurednerinnen zahlen für ihre Ausbildung bei mir.
Das ist sozusagen... kommt alles zusammen.
Oh nein, der singt auch dabei.
Oh Gott, da hätte ich ja Bock drauf bei der Hochzeit.
...Haltet euch fest, ein Leben lang.
Heute ist euer Tag und was auch kommen mag.
In einer romantischen Ferienwohnung im romantischen Bayern formte er ein Herz aus Mozzarella und Tomate.
Schön. Ist das nicht? Ja, also die Männer schreiben alle mit. Oh, super Idee.
Das ist das Schönste an dem Beruf eigentlich.
Wie ich sehe, wenn ich bestimmte Dinge sage oder sie auf...
...eine bestimmte Art und Weise sage, wie sich diese Menschen öffnen, wie ihr Blick immer...
Okay, da muss man sich mal lassen. Ohne Scheiß, ich fand, das hat er jetzt nicht schlecht gemacht.
Also man hat gemerkt, er hat sich mit der Sache auseinandergesetzt,
aber der hat das alles auch so weit aufgelockert und schon zu so einer bisschen...
...zu einer eigenen Nummer gemacht. Fand ich nicht schlecht.
Besser als irgendwie ein Bekannter, der dann was vor sich hin stammelt, ist es schon.
Und dann habe ich gefragt...
Welches sind die kleinen Gesten im Alltag, an denen man die Zuneigung immer erkennt?
Lisa hat geschrieben...
Läuft diese Motivationsmusik da im Hintergrund auch?
...nämlich nimmt, an sich zieht und küsst oder wenn er meine Hand nimmt.
Mein lieber Schatz, ich liebe dich, weil wir immer in die gleiche Richtung blicken.
Mit dem selben...
Ja, Gott. Ein bisschen cringe ist es schon. Nicht wegen ihm, sondern dieses ganze Gelaber bei Hochzeiten immer.
Wir sind zusammen stark und fangen uns gegenseitig auf, auch wenn Steine im Weg liegen.
Kraft eurer Liebe erklären wir alle euch zu Mann und Frau.
Und jetzt dürft ihr euch küssen und alle anderen...
Moment, macht das nicht der Pfarrer normalerweise oder der Standesamt-Typ oder irgendeiner?
Ich freu mich.
Der macht alles. Der macht alles.
Dann möchte ich euch natürlich noch bitten, die Trauerkunde zu unterschreiben.
Es ist sehr viel Spaß, den mir der Job bringt.
Und dementsprechend ist mein Job tatsächlich sehr wichtig.
Also, ja.
Wenig Hobbys.
Eigentlich bin ich eigentlich immer nur am Arbeiten.
Also, wenn ich's jetzt grad so überlege, ist es wahrscheinlich so eine Art Lebensinhalt.
Stop the feeling!
Oh Gott.
Peace.
Dance, dance, dance, yeah.
60 Trauungen pro Jahr.
Der ist quasi mindestens einmal die Woche.
Und wahrscheinlich auch an so beliebten...
Ich denke mal, es gibt ja so beliebte Daten.
Was weiß ich, Elfter, Elfter und was auch immer.
Da sind die Leute wahrscheinlich gerne, die heiraten.
Ausgabenumsatzsteuer.
Der ist richtig am Hascheln, genau.
Weiter lande ich ungefähr bei 3.500 Euro netto pro Monat.
Ja, wobei das bei mir natürlich, weil ich Saisonarbeit habe.
Das heißt, ich habe im August viel, viel, viel mehr Einnahmen, weil ich diese ganzen Reden halte,
als jetzt irgendwie im November, wo ich fast gar keine Traureten habe.
Was hat er denn hier?
Also, der nimmt 52.000 Euro ein.
Dann hat er einfach...
Gut, da muss er natürlich noch ein bisschen Zeug von bezahlen wahrscheinlich.
Ja, geht doch.
Ich meine, er ist davon jetzt vielleicht nicht super reich, aber kommt man doch gut hinaus.
In diesem Jahr ist es wesentlich mehr, weil das Portal tatsächlich gewachsen ist.
Weil die Ausbildung, ich mache viel mehr Ausbildung, als ich 2020 gemacht habe.
Da hatte ich gerade angefangen mit den Ausbildungen.
Und tatsächlich...
Da habe ich meine Preise angehoben und so kommt auch bei den Trauungen mehr rein.
Also, dieses Jahr wird es mehr.
Sehr zufrieden.
Man hat ja gesehen, die Braut war sehr, sehr dankbar.
Bin ich auch gut.
Ich meine, letztendlich, er hat ja auch das Risiko.
Und das ist halt alles, was man braucht.
Auch wenn die Gäste, wenn die mitkriegen, dass man geht und noch winken oder nochmal so machen,
die Bestätigung nochmal geben wollen.
Das ist einfach ein tolles Gefühl.
Da muss aber halt auch jemand sein, der gerne da vorne steht.
Sonst klappt das nicht.
Ein guter Job gemacht hat.
Ich gönne mir immer wieder, essen zu gehen.
Und manchmal dreimal am Tag.
Und wenn ich dann denke, oh Gott, wenn du das alles zusammenrechnest, was das jetzt gekostet hat.
Es ist verdammt viel Geld dann irgendwie.
Aber ich liebe das einfach, in Cafés, in Restaurants zu sitzen, die Welt um mich herum so ein bisschen wahrzunehmen.
Bin auch fast immer dann alleine auf dem Tisch.
Die volle Gönnung, ja.
Und ja, das kostet aber dann auch relativ viel Geld.
Das ist die Pizzascheune.
Hier gehe ich schon seit Jahren her.
Die Pizza, Salami, Bier abzumähen.
Der Klassiker.
So verbrennt sich ein Trauredner den Mond.
Ich nehme dann ein Bier.
Die pure Gier.
Einen Großteil meines Geldes spare ich tatsächlich und lege es dann oder investiere es in Dinge,
die mir wenigstens eine gefühlte Sicherheit dann geben.
Ich gebe einfach nicht das aus, was drauf ist auf dem Konto,
sondern ich gebe weniger aus, als was auf dem Konto drauf ist.
Dann liegt es auf dem Konto.
Und irgendwann, wenn genügend,
was drauf ist, kaufe ich mir etwas Werthaltiges, also wie z.B. eine Immobilie.
Hier ist meine Sauna.
Steht im Schlafzimmer und ist eine wunderbare Art und Weise dann nach einem Arbeitstag.
Private Sauna im Schlafzimmer.
The fuck, sowas gibt es?
Da runter zu kommen, dann setze ich mich da rein.
Hat er da eine 4090 drin wahrscheinlich, ja?
Witze natürlich, entgifte dadurch.
Dementsprechend würde ich da jetzt gerne ein bisschen Privatsphäre haben, wenn das okay wäre.
Also ich gehe in die Sauna.
Und ihr geht, wo immer man hingeht, nach einem Arbeitstag beim Bayerischen Rundfunk.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Und was will er sich denn entgiften?
Der kann sich gut verkaufen.
Das musste dafür auch auf jeden Fall.
Ist aber auch cool, was er da mit diesem Vermittlungsportal gemacht hat.
Hier geht es in die ARD Mediathek.
Da musste Max aus der News-WG nicht seine eigene Hochzeit, aber seine eigene Beerdigung organisieren.
Und hier geht es weiter.
Was verdient eine zahnmedizinische...
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Zahnarzt muss jetzt nicht sein.
Kein Zahnarzt jetzt.
Jetzt wissen wir auch Bescheid, was ein Trauerredner verdient.
Und da ist das Spektrum wahrscheinlich ziemlich groß.
Aber ich finde, der hat es gut verkauft.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich nie einen Trauerredner brauchen, weil ich nie heiraten werde.
Aber wenn ich heiraten würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht bestellen.
Dann würde ich es lieber einen machen lassen, der es schlechter macht, aber halt irgendeinem Bekannter ist.
Aber ich würde nicht, ich heirate eh nicht.
Insofern.
Aber er hat es gut gemacht.
So, was machen wir jetzt, Chat?
Ich habe Hunger. Es ist 12 Uhr.
Wenn er Twitch-E-Mails einbezieht, dann könnten wir noch mal drüber reden.
Ja.
TypeScript 5 is coming.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Was gibt es Neues bei TypeScript?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt noch schnell an, bevor ich essen gehe.
Wie bringe ich am einfachsten Filme vom PC auf den Fernseher?
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit?
USB-Stick? Je nachdem, was das für ein Fernseher ist?
USB-Stick?
USB-Festplatte?
Die meisten haben doch heute irgendwie so ein smartes OS drauf, wo du auf Filme von USB starten kannst.
Ja, klar, sowas wie Chromecast.
Wenn der Fernseher Chromecast hat, kannst du machen.
Langes HDMI-Kabel.
Gibt zig Möglichkeiten.
Okay.
TypeScript 5.
TypeScript 5.0 is coming out.
Das ist ein ASMR-Video.
This video is going to show you all of the cool things that are coming.
Like, there's tons and tons of stuff that they've got planned.
Okay, ich kann mir das, okay, das bringt nichts, wenn ich mir das angucke.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von TypeScript.
Das sagt mir gar nichts.
Ich kann mir das angucken und sagen, okay, ja, next, alles klar, ja, hm, next.
Ich habe null Planer vor.
Das bringt nichts, wenn ich mir das jetzt angucke.
Gebrauchtwagen, Achtung, Betrüger.
Ja, überall sind die Bescheißer unterwegs.
You will reconsider
Docker after
watching this.
Oh, ne, WebAssembly.
Was ist, okay, jetzt mal seriously,
was ist es mit diesem ganzen
Gelaber von
WebAssembly macht Docker überflüssig.
Das sind doch zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Das eine ist ein Container
Frontend und das andere ist, wie soll man
sagen, ne Runtime.
Das habe ich jetzt an vielen
Stellen schon gesehen. Was, was wollen die eigentlich
alle? Cloud yourself.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Moment, Moment, das Intro muss sein.
Das Intro muss sein.
Achtung.
Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz
kurz gezeigt. Korrekt.
Ich glaube, das letztliche Thema
interessiert mich nicht, aber
das Intro muss jetzt einfach sein.
In diesem Video
nur ganz kurz. Was zeigt er denn?
Direkt mit einem eigenen Server
starten. Wir können auch nur mit dem Rest
oder ob es eben beides macht.
Absolut so, wie wir
angemieteten VPS Server, da würde ich
wahrscheinlich. Easy, easy. Draw IO Build.
Kannst streamst du
mit dem Sprecher? Gar nicht, wir kennen uns null.
Ja, das kannst du mit
Java theoretisch auch.
Oder mit .NET.
Bis dann halt die Abhängigkeiten nicht
da sind, die man braucht.
Weil du vielleicht auf irgendwas
externes zurückgreifst. Ja, oder auf
irgendwelche Library-Geschichten, die installiert
sein müssen oder weil du vielleicht noch
keine Ahnung
eine Datenbank
brauchst oder einen Redis oder sonst
was. Deswegen meine ich das jetzt.
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, Docker kann jetzt ja auch
irgendwie WebAssembly Runtime
embedden oder so und dann wird ein Container
mit WebAssembly gestartet.
Wo das dann wieder
ausgeführt wird. Was der Sinn davon ist, verstehe
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz.
Müsste man sich vielleicht mal angucken.
In nächster Zeit.
Wir haben schon WebAssembly
gemacht in C++ im Stream.
Es war eines der high IQ-igsten
Streams Chat, muss man sagen.
Ein WebAssembly C++
Videoplayer, der Formate
im Browser abspielen konnte, die
normalerweise der Browser nicht unterstützt.
Das war schon nicht
ohne. Das war richtig
way to dank. Ich weiß schon gar
nicht mehr, wie es funktioniert, aber ich hab den Source Code noch
irgendwo. Wir könnten nachgucken.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das jemals
gepusht habe auf GitHub.
Auf...
Habe ich das
gepusht? Oder habe ich nur gesagt,
ich werde es pushen und habe es nie gepusht?
Schauen wir mal.
Sort.
Ne.
Nö. Habe ich nie gepusht.
Lul.
Docker versucht relevant zu bleiben.
Ja, das versuchen sie ja seit Jahren schon.
Mein Docker ist jetzt an sich
natürlich genauso relevant wie vor ein paar Jahren noch,
aber halt Docker, die Firma dahinter,
die wissen glaube ich nicht so genau, was sie damit machen sollen.
Swarm war jetzt ja nicht so
der Hit.
Ich habe gehört, dort wo ich mich
beworben habe, dort wo
ich demnächst nochmal ein zweites Vorstellungsgespräch
habe, die benutzen angeblich
noch ganz viel Docker-Swarm.
Wahrscheinlich hat da vor ein paar Jahren mal
irgendeiner mit angefangen und dann
hat man es halt behalten, weil es da war.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich habe Hunger.
12 Uhr.
Gucken wir, ob wir am Mittag noch ein bisschen was
basteln.
Aber ich gehe erstmal was essen.
Wir sehen uns, Leute. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you. Und ich habe jetzt Urlaub
bis Januar. Ich werde jetzt öfter
streamen in den nächsten Tagen wieder.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
PepoFatTime. See you.